Can we go
for three to
boom and we're live. Hello,
Miriam. Hi Joe. Good to see you.
Grab this mic and keep it
like a fist from your face.
That's a good reference
point. Perfect. Perfect.
Just like that. Yeah. Good
to see you. Good to see him.
I'm sad that you can't sell these
snacks everywhere because I know you're,
you're working on making these
mass produced, but they're
fucking fantastic. Yeah,
they're very good.
When did you first give me some of these?
Like five years ago or some shit.
Something like that. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. My knee blew out.
I just had surgery and I needed something
to do. So that was neat. Number one.
The second one, that was the second one.
And that was, and I've had two more sense.
I've had four total.
The life of a world champion.
Moyie Thai kickboxer not an easy one.
Actually started when I started,
we started at grappling. That's when it
started blowing your out. Yeah, yeah. No,
it was, I was, um, wait, time was
fine. It got cracked ribs. I got cut.
I got maybe concussions may be really
bad. Like broke my elbow on. Somebody had.
Yeah, but not, no, I'm
nice stuff. It was the MMA,
Jujitsu, wrestling and
Jujitsu. A rough on the knees.
This motion not awesome on the cartilage.
It's like a weird emotion.
You mean I'm like hip,
stuff like that with your,
so like a on your back or working
in guard, that kind of thing.
That's where you think that
it, well, I just, yeah,
and 20 years of use on this body.
Yeah.
Well it does put it put, it puts
weight in weird ways. He's too,
if someone's trying to pass your guard
and they're moving your ankles. Yeah.
Just swivel with their weight and
their violence directed at you. Yeah.
I saw you getting a bunch of fluid
on Instagram shot into there.
What is that all about? Like
Orthovisc what has that not help? No,
that was a waste of money. That
was, yeah, it was the Gulf,
like a gooey fluid padding. Oh, is
that what the idea is? But what was,
what was really nice as I got a straight
shot of Ibuprofen in there that felt
amazing. Like three months worth of
Ibuprofen. Just shot it right in there.
That shit is so bad for you
though. Is that it was, well
it felt really good. Yeah.
I tell everybody stay the fuck
away from my Ibuprofen. Yeah.
Doctor Rhonda Patrick is the first
person that alerted me to it.
The increased Reese of a risk of
strokes and heart attack. And then,
um, my friend Cam Haynes, who's
an ultra marathon runner, he um,
he was taking 800 milligrams a day every
day for how long? Forever. That's a lot.
It's a lot. That's different. It is
different. I just got one super shot.
Well he was wrong. He basically
runs almost a marathon a
day. Yeah, that's crazy.
Yeah. Cause he runs, he's 240 mile races.
So he was having these series paints
like he's like, I need it to get going.
So I told him about all the heart attack
stuff and the stroke stuff. He's like,
fuck.
So he gets off of it,
all of his inflammation
relaxes and calms down.
Turns out what was going on
was the Ibuprofen severely
upsets your gut bacteria.
And so when that happens,
it causes systemic inflammation,
which you then treat with Ibuprofen.
So he takes out the Ibuprofen, all the,
the gut problems go away. All the
inflammation goes away, all his hip pains,
knee pains, all that shit
went away, which is crazy.
I think Ibuprofen is great
if you do it every week,
just rarely, you know
something's going on. You need,
what I noticed when he shot my knee that
into my knee and meet like within the
next week,
you know,
over the course of a couple
of days I noticed that I
had greater range of motion.
So what it made me
realize, it was like, oh,
I had a little inflammation in there
cause I was kept thinking. It was like,
is it, is it the tissue tight? Is
this homeboy shooting the wounded?
What does he shoot it in here?
This is,
this is that stuff that
didn't have gloves on? Yeah,
it was have gloves on.
Fucking doctors. This,
where were you in a garage
somewhere? Free Clinic. Would it?
Oh Yo,
look at you.
So what does that Orthovisc
stuff supposed to do?
Like give it padding. Yeah.
It didn't really help.
It was a waste of money and time.
How much does that Shit Cross?
I think it was like 200 or two 20 I
shot and I just got three of them.
Well maybe it's for like regular people,
maybe it would work for regular people,
not for people to throw
him a lot of kicks.
You know the kicks don't bother me
and I bet it is the kicks. Right. I,
I think I think about that
like it is grappling, right?
That is the thing that puts the most
where on your, if you talk like you,
you meet like old kickboxers. I mean
some of them have brain damage for sure,
but their bodies aren't as
broken down as old. Grapplers no,
they might be humbling a little bit.
Know their toes, might kind of using rob.
Rob came in of him.
Rob Is Rob Rob's foot look,
look like he jumped into a pool that
was empty land and on his big toe.
Yeah,
all of them.
But when you're a guy like rob has been
kicking shins and elbows for so long,
he's amazing.
It sucks.
It hurts my heart that he missed the, um,
the, the current human said, you know,
the fame wave cause he's brilliant.
He's fucking brilliant.
He really is. Yeah. And he helped a lot
of fighters too. I mean he was a big,
big part of Br Brennan
Vera's early success and uh,
that's when I was training with them
bomb squad days. Yep. And you know,
he was working with a lot of kickboxers
and even people were starting to catch
onto his whole system, but I didn't
even when I got to work with him, um,
and I couldn't at the time
I was so,
um,
green as a fighter or just as a martial
artist that I couldn't comprehend what
he was trying to show me and
tell me. And he's like, no,
you're going to have programs,
counters to the counters.
And he was like trying to dial in me and
programming and I couldn't keep up with
him, you know, at the time it was
just too, and wasn't at that level.
Well,
you know what the difference is?
Like some people just use
athleticism and timing and they just,
they just try to be creative.
What he does is he has a full system of
like what to do in varying positions and
what to do depending upon
your opponent's reaction,
but then on top of that
there's also creativity,
which is and savagery. Yeah. Oh yeah.
He's a savage mother fucker. Yeah.
He's very sad. What is the highlight
reel? Pullup rob his highlight reel.
I mean he,
he not points stash in the right.
That's the thin.
Then rob came.
It's really incredible when you think
about like how many great fighters came
out of Holland and
kickboxers in particular.
It's just one small country
and here it is right here.
Get to see some of it. Look at, rob
came following up on a motorcycle.
Sexy Bitch.
So stoic to angry.
Well back in the day he was,
which is really interesting if you know
him now because he's so friendly and
huggy and he's like a big fluffy dog.
He's a fascinating guy. He really
is, but his, his knowledge of,
of kickboxing,
he's just so fucking tremendous.
I love how he sat down on
his punches like a boxer,
like shifting his weight
because he's,
I don't see a lot of kickboxers
that do that. Well yeah,
we're still here and then they
rotate, rotate, but they don't,
he's like really kind of getting in
here, you know, like a boxer more.
Do you think that's because
when you do dig down your,
is your sort of compromising your
ability to throw kicks for a brief moment
because you really digging in, but he's
knowing he knows when to do it too.
This his fight Iq.
Right.
It's knowing when to do it.
And it's also,
I s my pet peeve with we tie,
look at him.
My pet peeve with [inaudible] is when
they throw punches, they kind of come up.
It's like a very triumphant
looking isn't it? It's like,
and it's like that doesn't make any
fucking sense cause you won't punch with
power, not the same power. Um,
and you can't get out of the way.
Why do you think they do?
I didn't think that.
I just think they weren't taught well.
I wasn't,
I just recently started changing
my style. You know, but um,
when you kick you're up, you kinda
come up into the kick, you know,
like raise up and then they
try to punch in that way.
And I really feel like just
with mixed martial arts,
when you are doing wrestling,
you have to like be respectful
that you're doing MMA fight,
but kind of embody that, you know, that
wrestling technique when you're punching,
you got to embody that punching
technique when you're kicking,
you got to embody that kicking technique.
And same with Jujitsu.
Like you wouldn't stand as a Muy Thai
fighter if you're doing a wrestling move
right in an MMA fight, of course.
And I think with Moyie high fighters,
they don't understand that.
It's like when you're punching,
you're like kind of sit down and
rotate. You got a hotel. I like to say,
Oh take [inaudible] I have good hotel.
And then when the kick,
they got to come up when they need,
they got to come up. You know,
it's different and they don't make that
distinction. And then they don't produce,
they don't optimize on their body and
the power that they could produce.
That's always been a big issue with,
with MMA is fighters trying to figure out
exactly how to position themselves and
how to move and then all the variables,
right.
The how many different ways there are
to do it really successfully. Like UCL,
Conor McGregor stands wide stance kind
of sideways. He stands almost like,
like a karate guy a lot around his,
his strong weapons. Yeah. Yeah.
Whereas different guys have, you know,
different ways of doing like, you know,
Daniel Cormier, a very different style.
No hands up, high moves forward, you know,
a lot of Bob and weave in
as much more like a totally,
you gonna fuck if you get hit, you
get your handle on him though. No.
Or Connor does. Right. I kind of take it,
can you stay away from exactly. Exactly.
This is more like, come at
me, bitch grabbed me, but
I'm going to come and get ya.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Yeah.
Uh,
but it's uh,
it's fascinating also how a lot of people
that come from certain backgrounds,
like even wrestlers who come
from a wrestling background,
they have to alter their own wrestling
style for MMA. Like a lot of wrestlers,
specifically guys who stand in an Orthodox
position position when they're boxing.
But if there were a right handed wrestler,
a lot of times they'd be standing,
so yeah. And they'd be shooting with
the right leg forward. Uh Huh. Uh Huh.
So it's a lot of judo to yeah. Right.
Yeah. Yeah. It's a lot of weird,
like MMA is such a different thing.
It's so different.
There's so like it's where all the pieces
come together and some of them don't
line up that good.
Yeah. Yeah. I think the best people
are the ones that can make it line up.
Sure. Yeah. And that's
at the most fluidity
when you see,
um,
particularly you because you're a world
champion Muay Thai fighter and when you
see the level of standup in
MMA, for sure. Now with women,
it's the highest it's ever been right.
Like right around now.
But it's still not quite the level
that you would see in like championship
Moitai except for girls like Valentina.
Yeah.
She's amazing. Yeah. Cyborg
of course is very scary.
Yeah, she is. She's so
nice. Super Nice. Right.
This pulled out. Sorry. That's all right.
That's fair. Yeah. You can move it around.
Yep. There we go. There you go. All
right. Yeah. Um, yeah. Have you met her?
You'd be like, really? I feel
bad for making fun of her.
She made fun of her before.
Yeah. She's so nice.
She's, I'm just got to be like this
really a tender soul or heart. Yeah.
Which is funny because it seems genuine,
very genuine,
very, very genuine. And she's
matching people. It's like, yeah,
well that's genuine to,
Yup.
Yeah. It's like, so whatever
it is, it's 100% and that's,
and there's something a really,
um,
rare and, and then, uh,
so powerful because people
aren't 100% right. You know,
there aren't 100%, like fully, like,
just heartbroken, wide open, um, um,
soft and then they're not 100%,
you know, violence. Right.
And she's just like 100% so
cool about her. Yeah. Yeah.
That's interesting. Right? Like when she
fights, she's 100% [inaudible] violence.
Yeah. And that is, that's,
that's something that you see in a lot
of lot of champions. It's like there's a,
there's an ability like there's an ability
to be like a really nice person and
then a terrible person or I'm
not even a terrible person.
A furious competitor.
Yeah. You know? Yeah.
When you first started fighting,
did you just find that inside of you?
Did, you know it was always there,
like that's you ha cause you're,
you're a person that I,
if I had to like if I had explained you
like you're like very energetic and fun
loving, you're very nice person
skipping around your studio util fun.
Like you're a fun person hearing
when we probably met in like,
I want to say it was 2003
it was the bomb squad days.
I was about 28 yeah.
Bam.
42 the dizzy. Yeah. Right. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. But you've always been like that.
But then when I've seen you fight,
like this is a different Miriam,
Miriam, when Miriam comes
to fight, it's like, oh,
she got a little switch in there and
you hit a switch and then you become a
different person and then it's not
just that you're a competitor, you're,
you become super hyper focused and
aware and ruthlessly aggressive.
Yeah. Yeah. I, um,
did you know that was always in you
before you fought? Who is new? That I,
I would always have a trouble with
girlfriends and I mean like dating,
I mean like try to have a girl that's
a friend when I was younger because I
would hurt them. You've heard them
physically? Yeah. Accidentally. Yeah.
It was wrestling around with
this one woman all like, yeah,
we're going to be friends.
We're like the same height and we're
wrestling around and playing around.
If we were like partying in Vegas and I
were wrestling and I've wrapped my legs
around her rib cage and squeeze
and cracked something in there. Oh,
where were you? You were on
the ground. It's like utopia.
And then we went to this
after party afterwards.
And you were dressed like in my
twenties drunk or whatever, you know,
or whatever or whatever. And uh,
he was, my size is like, you know,
she wanted to wrestle too, so I
was like, oh, can't wrestle too.
And yet cracked something in there. Yeah.
She didn't want to be my friend anymore.
She was mad at you? Yeah.
It was really sad. Oh yeah.
Well you probably off light.
Anybody gets upset that, you know, it's
not like you meant to hurt her. No.
But Ivy prep, why the fuck that is a
weird thing that people do, right? I mean,
I've seen guys do it and girls do
it where they start play wrestling,
but they have no fucking idea
what they're doing. And then,
and then they hurt themselves and they
bite off more than they could chew. Well,
that's a common thing.
For whatever reason.
People get a little drunk or whatever
and then they want to wrestle.
So what I used to do is I used to let
people play around with me and then I end
up getting stabbed in the
eyes or with fingers. Oh yeah.
So now I don't, I'm like, all right, cool.
That's the number one draw with you
anymore. MMA for sure. They'll fucking,
I fucking hate it. There's so many
guys like look at my Michael Bisping.
He has one eye that's like completely
fucked up though. He's got oil in his eye.
They should um,
penalize more higher for that.
100%. Yeah, I think that, um,
that would the behavior with
disc decrease or think so too.
I think one point, I think one point for
a nut shot and one point for an Ebook,
just period. You didn't mean to do
it. That's great. But you did it.
So for the second not shot, no first note
shot first not shot first. I poke my,
because I don't have nuts, so I'm a little
bit more lenient on that one. I'm like,
oh well whatever.
Well,
Brian Foster is a dude who fought for
the UFC back in the day. He lost it. Nut.
So funny. Oh, dairy.
I knew somebody. Okay.
So now we're reminded me of this
guy that was at the old fair techs.
Clemon Tina when Backlund
Alex Khan was there and he,
so the rumor had it that
he had one ball and yeah.
And he was kind of grumpy and
sorta like insecure and yeah,
I guess so. So this I just thought
of him and it just made me laugh.
So it's not just what the hell's in
general? No, but that would be really,
that would be super painful
to lose one of those.
Apparently what happened was ruptures.
He was sparring and like,
like one last round decided not to wear
his cup and went out there and slam.
Whoa.
God took on right on the sac and
burst that he's still fighting.
I saw him, uh, on uh, uh, smaller,
uh, one of those, you know,
like a access TV fights recently to me,
like a breast implant is ruptured.
Oh there's so much.
It's all over the place.
A little breast implant helps
you through your system.
It would be like if a breast
implant helped you be a woman,
cause that's like the sac that produces
your testosterone, this stupid design.
Well another buddy of mine
lost one to cancer. Oh,
just impregnated is lady
[inaudible] still works. Yay.
You'll Duncan to Dunkin.
But um, we're talking about getting
kicked in the balls. Oh yeah. One point.
Just one point for Ipos.
One point for ball shots.
Just take a point away every time.
I think that would be giant.
I think that's fair. I would, it would
fucking hell so many people doing this.
The thing is we're good. I
poke, we'll change the change,
the change, the fight 100% it can, it
can sway the fight one way or the other.
Yeah. You know, so I, I don't, I, that's,
and people that they've
gotten poked in the eye,
the reflexive continue and then they
get fucked up and then they lose a fight
that they were winning.
Exactly. Yeah. That's terrible.
Terrible. It's a huge swing.
I think one point absolutely.
And I think there should be a better
way to determine whether or not a guy's
eyes had been compromised by that Ipos.
And sometimes it's not within the,
I mean everybody wants to
see the fight continue,
but if you really had to think about it,
like if this guy really can only see out
of one eye, it's not right. Yeah. Yeah.
Especially when it wasn't their fault,
but it's also such a fucking shit design.
All your fingers are just out there. Maybe
they should just curve them more. Yeah,
like the same design just curved.
They automate it.
Like when you have a good hand wrap,
like when they wrap your hands for
the fight. When it's a good one,
they just sit like this,
like your hands just sit there.
So they're just already ready
to, you know, it's perfect.
Well there's someone that I know that's
working closely with the UFC that's
working on new design,
but I think it's going to be okay.
But still the fingers are exposed.
I think almost like the fingers should
be covered and how are they going to
careers. But I think he covered it like
a bad glove. You know how bad gloves,
like those old school Everlast God
gloves be amazing for me. Yeah.
For a grappler. I don't think they'd like
that. You'd be good for grappler too.
If I had to ground mat gloves on,
I don't think I'd have a problem with it.
The weirder I grab the maybe you know
like a wrestler and then, I don't know.
I think the real, I think he'd
give you more traction. Honestly.
The real problem is
the pad on the knuckle.
Like when you're going behind the
neck where you're choking behind that,
it's very hard to get that fucker behind
the neck. Nothing's off that path. It is.
It's hard. I've grappled with, you
know, I've never had an MMA fight,
but I had grappled quite a bit
with with gloves. What do these,
does this aspiring grappling gloves and,
yeah. Yeah. Those are just like, um,
those are just a little bit
more padding, but those, yeah,
that's a little bit better. Pride gloves
were better. Honestly. Quite honestly,
cried gloves really had much more
curve to them and there was very few.
I pokes in pride.
I won't even fuck with a boxing glove.
That doesn't curve like it doesn't like
if I have to make a fist inside the
glove, I'm not going to
deal with that. That's good.
See this is like someone had observed
this a long time ago that look at the UFC
gloves on the right and the
pride gloves in the left.
The prod glove is your hands curve
the way better?
It's way better glove.
Yeah and the back of your hand
is like padded in a weird spot.
I don't know why they pad right here.
Like right above the wrist scope
would make that like right there.
The one that one though.
If you did a spinning back fist hit,
there's a little bones.
Yeah, right. They do break.
But most of the time you're doing that.
You're hardly ever doing it like a back
fist are kind of doing it like a hammer
fist and then the real thing is
happening with a lot of fighters.
Is there a hit and foreheads?
Snapping arms?
Paul felt that if you hit me
with, I'll be, I'll fucking,
you get mad. I get so mad.
And why do you get rid of
the
bullshit bullshit, bullshit
move, which is the bullshit.
Some people have moves that they feel
are bullshit moves like offended.
Like if somebody asks kicked you that I
don't care. That wouldn't be bullshit.
They pushed, kicked me in the face and
I wouldn't care. I'd be like, all right,
but it spinning back bullshit. But it's
so good. It's such a good technique.
Some fucking corn ball about that. Okay.
What about spinning elbows though? Yeah,
those are awesome and
I'm not great at them,
but that doesn't make any sense. I know
I contradict myself to excellence, right?
Yeah, it is weird, right? Yeah.
Well I mean I think they should
allow spinning back fist and boxing.
I'm like interesting
how everybody would be so
cocky. You know. So many guys.
They're sad. The boxing fans would
be, how many guys would get flatlined?
How many guys who don't know
what the fuck to do about it?
You're standing plan superman punches.
Well,
superman punches.
I think our legal right.
They react the same way,
right? No one would think you
throwing a leg kick. Why is,
why is mine cause cause you have
all these hair. I'm bald as fuck.
Oh there we go. There
you go. That's better.
Okay. Um, yeah,
but why can't they spinning back fist in
boxing? I don't know. Should be able to,
they are very purist,
but I see where they're
coming from in a certain way.
Like when boxers talk shit
about MMA and striking in MMA,
I see where they're coming from the
wrong because your shit won't work.
Like come try that shit.
You're going to get taken down stupid.
Like this is the whole reason
why they do it a different way.
But I actually do believe that a boxer
with incredible footwork and a jab,
a great job could survive and win in an
MMA fight as long as he doesn't fight a
long guy with good kicks,
like a Jon Jones,
Jon Jones just kicked the shit
out of you from a distance.
You're not even going to get close to him.
And then by the time you've
eaten all those leg kicks,
you're not moving so good.
Yeah. And Smash your face. I
agree. Yeah. But yeah, I think,
I think footwork is key. Do you remember
when Vince Foster, when he was a shit,
not quite world class anymore.
He'd lost a title and this is what
worries me because I don't remember shit.
You don't remember shit?
Well, he fought Masato,
but when Masato was the
king of k one over Japan,
Masato the sexiest Japanese man I've ever
seen. Pretty sexy. Yeah. He's super lazy.
Sexy isn't sexy.
Yama,
I dunno know sexy yama is
what you don't know. Sexy,
sexy on fought in the UFC several
times. Fought in pride. Yeah.
I don't know who that is. That's a great
name now. A gorgeous, gorgeous man.
Feel like that should be a super Sushi
roll areas. There's sexy yama autos.
Way better looking. Yeah. You say that
you're not succeed, yamas presence.
Look at that. I like the way glows. Yeah,
look at them. I mean it was beautiful,
but those pecs, yeah, he's got
that cross dangle and super low.
What's going on with that?
You look that cro,
it's almost like a belly button ring or
some shit. That's a deal breaker, right?
A dude with a belly button ring.
How about that?
A guy or a gorgeous guy with a
belly button ring. He's freaky.
Is that what it means? He vein
or gay as fuck. More likely.
That's something men just never rubbing.
It means he's freaky or he takes too
many cell face. Yeah, it definitely does.
She either.
So yeah,
that's something any man's ever
bravely tried to rock my note. Guys Do.
Nipple rings, like a real freaky dude.
We're doing it once you've seen it.
A belly button ring on a male.
One time I saw a pierced.
Who's that?
Masato there it beautiful.
I thought you were showing
me a belly button ring.
There's better pictures of him. There
is better. He's really good looking.
Very handsome and still is and
you know, and and still, you know,
is very active and all sorts of uh,
promotions and stuff.
Japan, when he fought no,
when he was gonna Fight Petrosian and
portrays you and was killing sour.
And what happened? It was supposed to be
his like, uh, there's one song. Goodbye.
Yeah. Yeah. And so he's watching
Petrosian Dis, I think it was sour.
Destroy any sour and, and, uh,
he's just like, fuck, he's like, pull up
Masako versus, um, Vince Philips.
Because what was interesting about this,
it was a, it was like, do you remember
when I'm Shannon the cannon, um,
decided to fight in k one and he fought,
uh,
Tom Erickson and a kickboxing
match. No, you don't remember,
but that was a similar thing, but
Tom Erickson was not, you know,
Tom Erickson was a wrestler who's an
MMA fighter and a Shannon Briggs eight,
a couple of leg kicks and it was talking
about it on the podcast like that.
He was trying to play it off. It was
like, God damn, that shit hurt. But, uh,
he wound up Kaylyn,
Tom Erickson,
but Tom Erickson at the time was not
nearly the kind of Stryker that Vince
Phillips was when Vince
Phillips Swap Masato.
Vince Phillips had beaten worldclass
fighters, I think. Who did he beat?
He beat some fucking high
level worldclass boxers.
And then, you know, we got like 36,
37 38 and then took this
fight was 37 at the time.
Uh,
I don't know.
So he fought Vince Phillips,
but it was so weird seeing a Vince
Phillips walk out there barefoot.
I mean they should have let him wear
boxing shoes cause he's not thrown into
kicks. Yeah. And Masato just
gimme gimme some fit. Beautiful
Man. Perfect bone structure.
He's ridiculous.
Perfect hair to English.
And Vince Phillips was like, what
the fuck did I sign up for? Yeah,
that feeling that they have when they're
at the shoulder about to get leg kicked.
So right away you opens up inside
and just moves away from the punches.
Sets goes up high.
It goes up high punched times kicking into
the arms and that goes across the leg.
See that's a, that's a weird one right
there across the thigh. Not Shot,
but this was, this is at the time,
like one of the first times that a,
a real world class boxer had attempted
a kickboxing fight and know that's um,
friends both. It did that too.
Do you remember frowns both up?
He was a heavyweight contender and
boxing in the eighties and nineties
to watching fights.
If you talked to my wife and ask her
what she told me about 10 minutes ago,
I will not remember what the fuck she
said was a lot of shit that I don't
remember. But I have like storage
units in my brain and stuff like, oh,
that's interesting. What happened there?
This happened. Oh, why did that happen?
Why did this go wrong? Oh, okay.
Pull up a Georgia Petrosian versus um,
uh,
Andy Sour as a u e r does it know,
how's it highspot Oh,
here's friends both. Yeah.
So you, so friends both.
This is France both at fat as fuck
too. He had like, he had hit the wall.
He was the white buffalo.
He's a South African heavyweight,
but he,
uh,
he actually learned how to kick a little
bit and he was not just boxing guys,
but his, his hands were just
way better than most boxers are.
Most kickboxers rather cause
he was at one point in time,
a real heavyweight contender.
This is not a good example then,
which was 2015. Holy Shit
Dude, that this is 2000.
This guy was a fucking contender
in the 90s he's already hurt.
Yeah. This is, she had thrown a knee.
Did you watch the chocolate Dell fight?
I just the end of it.
Yeah. Not Good. Right?
How old is he now? 50 yeah,
so there's hope for me.
Well, you've never been
knocked out the way he's,
he's been knocked out so many times.
I don't think I've ever been knocked out.
Not In the gym. Not ever flash,
flash knockdown. That's it. Yeah.
I've had concussions and been knocked out
from like falling and the rain falling
off a second floor
landing when I was a kid,
but in fighting and ever
[inaudible] trucks also,
I think there was an issue with his style
because his style was so aggressive,
aggressive that people
could just set, set, set,
boom and counter like
Rashad Evans did with him.
And so you're getting his momentum coming
forward and the shy and we get flat
line. It doesn't change.
No he doesn't. No.
He had a style that was incredibly
effective back in the day.
I think he became married to
that. That approach. You know,
the approach that works so well on Bob
Ballou so well on Tito in the early
fights,
he was just a marauder.
You could hit him in the face with a
fucking crow bar and he would just spit
metal out at you. You didn't give a
fuck. He was so bad ass back in the day.
He relied on that so much. I remember
all the no hawks. Yeah. Everybody,
a little kid to wear
Mohawks back in the day.
People will get in Japanese
symbols tattooed on their
head because of him. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. It's just that, that style,
there's a comes a certain point in time
and you just can't do that anymore.
You know, I think, um, I dunno,
like it's a martial artist,
you know,
artists evolve and they're like,
oh, well let me try this new paint.
Oh, let me try this, this,
this a new technique.
Let me try this shading. Let me, you
know, start sculpting. Let me try.
And I think with, uh,
especially MMA, you know,
there's just so much opportunity
to evolve and just add new, new,
new nuances to you as an artist. I mean,
I think that's what I love about it.
There's certainly is,
but one thing that does happen when,
when God's try to add a lot of things,
like say sometimes they'll try to like
say a wrestler will add a bunch of things
to his repertoire,
but then they stopped with the wrestling.
Wrestling is not as sharp and so then
when they go up against a really good
wrestler,
they falter and then they're,
they don't have what brought them
to the dance in the first place.
But I think that's just looking at your
opponent and what's in front of you.
And also like being honest with yourself.
And like I think right now I'm looking
at getting back into fighting and if I
didn't feel the sharpness,
I didn't, I didn't feel the
fire and not just the fire.
If I didn't physically feel the sharpness,
if I didn't feel the reflexes,
I'd have to be honest with myself
and say, okay, don't do this.
Do you think that you would oh 100% be
capable of being rational and objective
about what you can do right now?
Yeah, yeah. Because I don't,
I don't fight for participation awards.
You know what I mean? Like I'm not like,
Hey, I'm a, but there's some UFC fighters
are like, I'm a UFC fighter. Yay.
I've made it. Like that's not really
making it. You're just another, you know,
like say I'm a world champion,
I'm a the best in the world. Emma,
that's like I'm a UFC fighter is like
a participation medal basically like
level. It shows that you're
a very high level fighter.
You're very right. But you and
your eyes, you as a champion,
that is what's important.
You want to be the queen.
You want to be a top of the hill
to the best of your best self. Yes.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Um, uh,
this one thing that I really
like about individual sports,
whether it's Jujitsu or Moy,
tai or any or boxing,
is that you can focus on just one sport
and all the various aspects of one
sport. And there's so much subtlety in
so much technique and so much to learn.
I mean you were what? Watch Floyd
Mayweather senior train people.
It's really interesting because he's
showing guys who are world class fighters,
like the subtle subtle aspects of boxing
and movement and things they're doing
wrong. He, you know, Simon Marcus,
he was working with Simon Marcus and he
was doing some training with sidewalks.
I'm like, this is so fast and had to
be hired for a guy like Simon. Yeah.
Cause he's a very rigid yes.
And he's,
he gets so much power from his rigidity
and so like boxing is much more,
it's not rigid. Right. You
know, it's like hip hop.
We know that it's got that, like that
beat to it and that like swag to it.
And Simon Marcus is just so that Moy
Thai style and a lot of grappling moving
forward. Yeah. He's a very
physically strong guy too. Yeah.
He looks like he's on Shit. Yeah,
he does. Hey good. Janine's jeans.
I remember Joe Schilling.
Yes I is. Yes. Is that beef?
Fuck yeah, that fourth. I can't remember
what a fucking crazy fight that was.
I was there for that. And it was all
the controversy on the first one. Right.
Cause it wasn't that there was
the illegal, was it illegal?
He hooked the back of the heel
or something. And then on the,
on the throat, on the, yeah, he,
this was the first fights.
So the first one at first fight Simon
Marcus one, but it was like a knot.
He got knocked out.
Right. So did from he, uh,
when Simon fell on him and he also
put his, he foot behind his heel.
Right. I guess. And there was
a lot of conscious about that,
whether that was legal or not.
And then when he fell on him,
I guess he hit Joe in the head, in the
jaw with his, his forehead or something.
And so Joe got up like this. Did you
remember that? Yes, I do now. Yeah.
Yeah. So the revenge that avid in
that last man standing tournament,
which was a fucking crazy
thing to begin with,
where they were going to have to fight
three times in a night. Yeah. Yeah. So,
uh,
they fought in the first round.
Joe Fought Simon and it went
three rounds and it was a draw.
And so in the fourth round they had to
come out. Both guys were like, holy,
you know, Gloria goes one
more round. There's like fuck.
And Simon Marcus had kept spitting out
his mouthpiece and big John McCarthy took
a point away.
He goes,
he takes a point away from Simon because
Simon was exhausted as they were going
to war for three pl.
Absolutely. Yeah, absolutely.
He was spitting on his mouthpiece,
peck, trying to gain some time.
Now he's pretty fucking Jack,
Jack.
And so now he's got one point down
going into a fight. That's a draw.
So he's got to move forward.
So he comes after Joe and Joe
knows he's got to come at him.
So Joe starts countering and he catches
him with this fucking nasty right hook.
I think it's coming soon. Right
here. Three or four seconds.
Well it was a wild fight.
Just a wild series of exchanges and
I think Simon, yeah, here it is.
Simon's moving forward. Boom. There it is.
And Simon had knocked Joe
down early in the fight.
I think he knocked Joe down in the first,
so he,
so Joe lost the first round and then
we'll probably one the second and third.
So it was a tie going into the fourth.
Wow. Yeah, it was a crazy
fight. Awesome fight. Doe.
They actually fought in lion
fight too. I've, I've, if I,
I've had a lot of concussions could be
wrong, but I thought it was the plot
controversy.
Yeah.
And then the second fight was in line
fight and it was winner take all the purse
and then I think it was glory. Mm. Yeah.
I think you're right. Yeah, that's,
that was round to get knocked down.
Yeah. Yeah. I, I loved lion fight.
I wish they'd kept it on access TV.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
I don't know where it is now. I think
it's like on a web app or some shit.
I was afraid to fight line fight because
of the judging really screwy decision.
It was just like, but it's not an athletic
commission thing. That seems more ago.
Athletic Commission thing than a lion
fight. It doesn't matter because whatever,
if they keep doing it in the
same spot so it doesn't matter.
So say the case with Vegas though.
I mean Vegas has some terrible fucking
judging sometimes. Yeah, and it's not,
I mean, I don't know how you
fix that other than fire.
Anyone who has any shitty decisions
and it seems like you can't even,
you can you petition, you can, but
nobody wins. See, that's fucked up.
It is fucked up.
I can't imagine when has anyone in your
recent memory or in your memory period
when is anyone appealed a decision and
one I've never, I've never heard of it.
[inaudible] that's crazy.
You think about all the fights that we've
seen and that we've never, we don't,
we can't even recall someone
who got fucked who went
back and reviewed the tape.
Look, I, I'm hitting him three to one,
two to one and it still lose
decision which has happened.
Yeah, that has happened.
There's been some agregious
horrible decisions
at, I hate about this
is I think that these,
the judges don't really think about
that. It's our lives. I think if,
if I have this loss because of your era,
the next time I fight I make less money
and I'm already not making that much
money. Like you're not even
thinking about how, how,
what this does to me as, as
an, as a fighter, you know?
Yeah. It doesn't, um, I don't think
that it's, they're not thinking about,
I think
it's, they're not competent.
I think when there,
I think there's certainly corruption
and there's certainly people that get
bribed. I guarantee that does still
probably happen. How do I guarantee?
Probably I can't write,
but I think more likely than that
is you're seeing incompetence.
I think you're seeing people that
don't have any martial arts training.
That's fucked up though.
Then that it's ego.
Like I can admit that they don't
know, oh my God, I had that job.
I fucking had that at a,
I was a WBC title defense and I'm
doing completely legal throws it,
I'm way high throws and he's telling
me no more slamming her on the canvas.
He's like, he says this
ain't no Jujitsu. No.
Literally People's, yeah. Oh yeah.
I said his name as Voldemort.
Oh my goodness. Tom, you have a,
your wins commission appeal retains
to FC champion. Wait a minute.
What is the commission appeal though?
What does that mean though?
That might be lost a submission and the
other person was a champion for 13 days.
She lost by submission, Huh? Yeah.
This was in at the end of 25th.
2016.
How has it overturned to a no contest?
I had that. So what did, what happened?
I googled your question and someone found
some examples of it happening and this
was one of the three I found.
Oh Huh.
That's a little different cause that
seems like there was an error in the
officiating. And so if, if she lost by
submission and then they said it wasn't,
it wasn't legit. I had a decision
overturned. Did you really?
It was a fuck. What's
his name? John. Bigger.
The big rough.
Okay.
What's the name of John Big? John
McCarthy. John McCarthy. John Bigger.
It's a thing that they got the name John.
Um,
but I need a down deponent in the
head. Oh. But from where I was,
I didn't realize that. So I need her
once and she was like this. I was like,
Oh man, let me make sure this is
over with and I need her again.
But she was like five [inaudible] 11,
six feet ish, just among Duke super,
super long. And I didn't realize that
she was hired or knees or on the canvas.
I didn't know Justin Duke fought
Moy. Tai? No, this was an MMA. Oh,
I knocked her out, but, and
then I put one for good measure.
Oh, unfortunately, unfortunately he gave
me the win and then she appealed. She uh,
yeah, appealed it and then it
got overturned to a no contest.
It's not a DQ cause I mean I
didn't realize. Right, right.
That's interesting. Hm. Yeah. Cause
she would gone out anyway. Yeah. So I,
I've kind of fucked myself.
I gave her a leg to stand on.
Yeah. Hmm. Yeah. That was, that
was like, what organization
was that in? INVICTA. Mm.
How many fights do you have in
Invicta? Oh, three. Three I think.
How many is that all the most MMA fights
you bad. Oh God. Three right? Four. Four,
I think four. Now, when you talk
about coming back now, and I know,
you know you're recovering from
knee injuries and all this jazz,
what are you thinking of? Chunkiness
he looked great now. Yeah.
It's so much better because of snacking,
Modo,
no Nakamoto, healthy snacks. It man,
when you're 40 pounds overweight, you
smelled different. Do you know, like not,
not yourself. It's not yourself. This
is not 40 pounds. A lot is a lot.
What were you eating or not eating
or drinking all the time. Oh,
you're not working out and like limping.
Cause my name is cell. Fuck yeah.
This is a lot of a lot of grief.
Yeah.
But um, for someone like
you, it's gotta be hard to,
because you're so connected to
like your physical activity.
So to have that removed
and taken away from you,
well that was a mirror where you're
talking about like finding out who you
really are, who you think you are getting
that injuring, gaining all that weight.
I was like, oh, okay. Who I think I
am. I no longer have access to that.
So now who am I?
You know?
And it was like spent the last five years
trying to work that shit out. So yeah,
that happens. A lot of fighters
when they retire. Yeah. Okay.
I think I have it already.
What were you thinking? Well,
that time was up because you've got
to feel like also you're 42 now,
so this is all happening at 37 which is,
you know,
for some fighters it's towards
the end anyway. Yeah, no,
I was doing well at 37 I was doing
fine. No, you're doing great.
But there's a reality of
the clock. Yeah, for sure.
When you look at at least historically,
everyone outside of Bernard Hopkins,
he's amazing. Fucking amazing. Holy Shit.
46 years old fighting world class. I mean,
I think he beat,
did he beat Kelly Pavlik when he was like
46 I think he box Kelly Pavlik up when
he was 46 and lost to Joe Smith.
I think he was 51 but by the time we got
knocked out and sent out of the cage or
out of the ring. Oh, that guy.
Yeah, I know. He's amazing. Amazing.
43 when he fucking pablet he's like more
conservative now. Yes. When he fights.
Well he's done. But yeah.
Well he's a just recent stuff.
A masterful boxer just
absolutely understands
everything about boxing and he's
not going to put himself in a position
where he's going to get fucked up until
he couldn't help it anymore.
Like the Joe Smith fight.
It was like this has gotta be,
this is going to have yet and left too.
It felt like cove was lighten them up
also like, oh I don't want to watch this.
You know, it hurts when you see
somebody so incredible when they're,
you know, when it's done.
Yes. Cause they just,
yeah. Yeah. I actually think
you're so much better than this.
It's especially like
when they're an artist.
Like there's something about when
you see chuck go out on a shield,
something about it to me,
I don't seeing it for sure.
I definitely would have liked it
if he didn't get knocked out again.
But one thing that I would,
I would like young fighters
to see is that this is,
there's consequences to choices in
terms of like how you approach these
exchanges and how you,
how you fight and then I'm,
I'm of a belief that you
should fight the correct way.
Don't fight the way that pleases your
boss or the crowd fight the way you,
the way you're supposed to
with your skills. Like yeah,
and win by knockout when you can,
but don't get knocked out because you're
trying to win by knockout and doing
something that you're overextending
yourself and exposing yourself and you're
compromising yourself.
Like that's not wise.
And I think part of fighting has
to be wise. It's exciting enough.
I mean it's fucking crazy and wild
enough but everybody wants every single
second of it to be filled with blood and
the crowd cheering and when they're not,
I mean how many times have we seen
fights where just there's a lull in the
action for a brief moment or they're
clinching and people start booing and then
someone caught mix it up. Boys mix it
up. Like, what do you mean mix it up?
The fuck are you do, what do you think
they're doing, man? They're fighting.
This is crazy talk, you know,
like you see it all the time.
Social media brain,
this is a little bit of that patient.
What everybody wants to be
a huge star two, you know,
everybody wants to do their best to
gain the most followers and get the most
love and gets the most applause.
You know,
there's a right way to fight
in a wrong way to fight.
And one of the things about watching guy
like chuck go out on a shield like that.
It's like this is the bed he made.
I mean,
this is his style. His style is
Marauder Berzerker move forward.
Like Melvin Manhoef. When you see Melvin
go out on his shield, you go, look,
this is Melvin style. Yeah, yeah,
that's true. But if you see a guy like
sugar ray Leonard and he gets Kao,
do you like, oh Jesus, like
stop. You can't do it anymore.
Yeah, you're not really,
you can't, you can't move the
way that made you successful.
Pernell Whitaker or something like that.
If you see them for, for whatever reason,
they can't move. Right. Do you remember
Pernell Whitaker? I know the name,
but I haven't watched
hi damn woman as I was just letting,
I'm like man,
he was a defensive genius.
Olympic gold medalist, 76 I'm,
I'm terrible. So people ask me,
they will ask me about the why crew,
Rob Mccoy and I'm just like,
I dunno,
it's both. Or they'll ask me, how
do you win a Moitai fight? And I go,
I don't know,
do more damage.
Like I don't fucking know what
scores higher elbow or knee or punch.
I don't know. It just fucking win. Right?
Like I have no idea where you
ever thinking what scores higher.
Just thinking I'm going to dominate this
motherfucker. This is my space. Yeah.
Like this is my, you know, yeah.
It's square a circle or what is that?
How You thinking about it? This is mine.
Well, yeah, cause I think you, you,
you dominate the space and like
it's about territory, you know,
and findings territory and
you start and it's even,
and they have to their side and you have
your side and you take the territory
away and you want them to feel like
it's not, there is space anymore.
Like that's how you impose your will.
You know what I mean? Yeah. Yeah.
It's as simple.
I Dunno,
I dunno about fucking points
and this and that and it's shit.
Do you have no idea? Do
you ever teach? Uh, yeah.
Do you teach private lessons? Do you
teach classes? Like what do you teach?
A little bit. Yeah. Yeah. Do you ever work
with fighters? Um, I have. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
When you do it,
do you find that looking at it in a way
we were trying to explain it to someone
who's also trying to do what you do,
that it helps you understand what you do?
Um,
yeah.
Yeah. But I definitely
don't. You don't like it?
No, no. I, I, I still like
this conversation is the same.
Like it's more about like the tone you're
setting rather than the weapons you're
using. [inaudible] to me because it, it's,
it's really just like there's that
space and it's your job to own it.
[inaudible] you know, like you
own the center of the ring. You,
you dictate where they go. You take
things away, you know? It's like a,
it's an ex convict trying to get a job.
The doors just shut in their
face shut in their face.
Everywhere they turn shut in
their face shut in their face.
And interesting way to look like that's
how you want to make them feel like
you're approach. I don't, I don't want to,
I don't want an x comic to not be
able to get a job right in the ring.
You want to take shit away from somebody
and make them feel very discouraged.
Yeah. Yeah. Like you don't belong
here anymore and you know that,
you know, like that's what you
want them to feel. Yeah. Yeah.
And you don't want to fight me again.
That's another thing.
You want to make the field do, you
know, like this is these things.
So you've got to understand
what you're doing there.
But insofar as like what scores
higher and what did this and the,
I don't fucking know, but for no fucking
idea, which just goes off of like how,
how my opponent is reacting to
what I'm doing to them. Right.
How they're reacting to me and that's
what I'm going to throw or where they move
and that's what I'm going to throw.
I don't think about like, oh,
is this going to score? Should I throw
this or this? Which will score higher.
Right. You can't, I don't know.
It's fucking retarded. Yeah. Yeah.
It's not a wise way to think,
I don't think.
I think especially in
something like more time,
which so many fights win by knockout
and so many fights are won by knockout.
Yeah. And it's such a, such
a devastating art. You know,
we think about just having the ability
to kick and knee and punch and elbow and
all these different weapons you using.
I think we thought it doesn't hurt
that much. What does that mean?
What does that mean? Boy,
ty doesn't hurt that much.
Were talking about earlier about
breaking your elbow on someone's head,
but that didn't hurt at the time. At the
time it didn't hurt but adrenaline. No,
I mean it is like,
it just Bam. And I'm like, whoa,
she's bleeding. It's crazy.
And the refs like pulling me off her
and I don't think about how it felt.
I don't think about,
you know,
like when I got my ribs cracked
from a kick and then we tie fight,
I thought it was liver, so I was
like, I feel my pain. I'm like, no.
And then I'm like,
fuck you.
I'm in the fight and you pull yourself
back out of that pain cause you don't
want to fall into the pain because
it's hard to climb back up.
It's like swimming up,
up, um, upstream. Right.
So you kind of kept falling to
that fucking pain and uh, but it's,
it's not, it's, I mean, it's
banged up, but it's not that bad.
Well, you don't have a tolerance
for it. Yeah. I just like, I mean,
your shins will be bruised
up, you know? I don't,
I mean we were up on Instagram once
of your legs. I know that hurt.
That really hurt.
What day was the week after the fight that
your legs were that fucked up? No, no,
no. That was right before I fought.
It was right before you Vaughn? Yeah,
so I had three fights and that one was
about right before the last one. Oh,
you're three fights in a day? No,
I had three fights over five days,
which made it worse actually because if
the three fights I've been in one day
then these,
yeah,
so they had a day between each and
so the pain would set in and yeah,
it was Ifma. Was it in Thailand? Oh,
they're crazy over there. It was cool.
I liked it. That's wild. But that
shit hurt. That shit her for weeks.
Like I couldn't roll over in bed
like they couldn't, they couldn't,
you know how you stack your legs
and you snuggle up in your position?
Couldn't I had to and like put a
pillow in between them? Yeah. Oh,
there was the bruising was behind
on the calves like it was, it was,
I got kicked in the front. Yeah.
But there's so much blood, you know,
internal bleeding from the bruising.
It went to the back to my cap.
So it actually is Cirque and
calculating my whole leg and bruising.
And then it went down, um, my ankles,
both sides and then down to my toes.
So you took the pictures, that was you
in between the second and third fight.
That was the bright before the
third fight I was waiting at,
it was the king's cup that says the king's
birthday. Yeah, it's, yeah. So that's,
yeah. And you can see my ankle and
it actually went underneath my toes.
And this is before there was a fight
again. Both legs were like that.
Both were like this and you have to
fight again. Yeah. So do you know what?
And Matt Johnson on,
that's him rubbing me.
And so he tried to give me the white tie.
They give you the preflight
massage with the tile in it.
He couldn't fucking touch me. Is it
so bad? Fuck. Did you fight like this?
I don't know, but I did.
That is so insane. Yeah. And
their legs are so banged up,
the fact that you fought. Yeah. Yeah. And
it's so like mentally I was just like,
wow, this is, this is, this is
happening, this is, I'm going to do this.
And I'd look at my legs, okay,
okay, this is happening, this is,
this is okay. And yeah, just
started fighting. What did you feel?
I don't think about that. Sometimes you
get kicked in, it gets, it goes through,
like it gets through here for shield, you
know, like you kind of put up this like,
I dunno when I fight, it's like
I'm fighting and thing. Yeah.
It's a four shields in a
sense, you know? Um, and uh,
sometimes if it hurts enough, like when
I got my ribs cracked, I felt that right.
I can went through and I like disrupted
my force shield and so sometimes that's
something we'll go through like a good
solid were killed. So my four shields for,
she'll activate your attitude, your
mindset. This is like you're fighting,
you're, you're ready to accept all
sorts of things. Yeah. Like I could die
or even harder.
I could kill someone if you think it'd
be harder to kill someone than to die and
so on. You. Yeah. Yeah. Because then
you think about their loved ones.
So looking at all the people
that loved you, we fight.
Think about all the people that love
you. Right? Yeah. And so when we fight,
I didn't, I didn't break any
rules, but I killed you. Right.
I think about all your loved ones.
Everybody that loves you with,
that's attached to you. I
think about that, all that pain
because of what I did to you. Right.
Even though I didn't break any rules.
Have you ever been in a
promotion where someone died
but that's heavy, right?
Yeah. And I don't,
I think probably why a lot of fighters,
I have noticed like there's,
there's,
I don't think the majority of fighters,
um,
look at what they do with
the gravity that it deserves.
You know,
like you could kill somebody.
Like you need to think about that
and be okay with that. Not Okay,
but just understand like,
all right,
that could happen and I'm going to be
co a calm consciously knowing this and
choosing to go forward. They
just think, oh, I'm going
find it. It'll be fun. It'll,
you know, whatever. Or it'll be
hard or I'm gonna like whatever.
They don't think about these things.
Is this something that you thought
about when you were young? Yeah,
before I really got into
it. So you, this is, uh,
something you've been contemplating
even before you started fighting,
you are aware of all the
possibilities? Yeah, I,
okay. All right. I'll say it.
So I was, um, it was about 28,
I think, and I don't think I
had my pro boxing debut yet.
And I took some mushrooms
and I was thinking somewhere
along the trip I started
thinking about fighting and I started
thinking about like what could happen to
me.
And I think I started thinking about the
death of me and then I started thinking
about what could happen to my
opponent. Like, what's worse than that?
And I thought about ice could see like
somebody I fight and I saw all the like,
like lines of gold threat
attached into them like uh,
from their loved ones.
And then all the got snipped when
they died. Yeah. I saw this loan,
this mushroom trip, and I was just like,
fuck. And so then when I decided to fight,
there's more intense,
you know,
and more commitment and more
resolve. That's heavy. Yeah.
Yeah. But that is what it is. Right.
And that's where I think real,
there's more power
to people that have never fought before
and people that don't understand finding
they did this or I don't get the appeal.
I don't know why you watch it,
that the reason that p one of the reasons,
there's many reasons,
but one of the reasons why people enjoy
participating in it so much is because
there's so much risk and it's so
dangerous and it's so difficult,
so unbelievably difficult to prepare.
Unbelievably difficult to put
yourself in the proper mind state,
specially to be a champion,
to,
to beat the best of the best and to get
to the top of the heap that once you do
succeed,
like explain that feeling to people,
explain that feeling when they raise
your hand and put that belt around your
waist and the crowd is cheering.
I'm kind of weird cause I actually
get depressed. You get depressed,
you get depressed when you,
when uh, at times, yeah. Or,
or I'm just,
I think for me,
what I've come to realize about
myself is that it's about authentic.
They expressing myself in the moment.
And I think with a lot of my fights,
I wasn't being honest.
I didn't take my heart and cut it open
and pour it out on the mat or the canvas.
I played it safe. I didn't go in for
the knockout. I didn't slip a punch,
encounter and,
and get inside.
I stayed outside or when I was inside
I would clinch up an elbow and knee,
you know? So, um,
for me it hurts when I'm being
inauthentic. And I know that
with pretty much all of my
Moy Thai fights, I wasn't,
but is that the case or is it you
being hyper critical of yourself?
Always. Always. Oh, I said,
so I've, I've actually can,
you just said carry it on and
he can attest to this. I've,
I've come out of fights and, and won
the world title. It's done a great job.
And I co into the gym the next week
and it carried, this was stupid.
I looked stupid. I didn't do
this right. This is fucked up.
I can't fight like that again. Like we got
to fix that. And it was just like that.
That's what makes a champion though.
Yeah. But mine was unhealthy,
so mine was more,
I think,
I think I'm more of a champion now than
I ever was when I was actively fighting
and when I was, um, I was
okay
trying to be good enough
instead of just focusing on
how can I say, my, my,
my pursuit of world titles
wasn't, wasn't about it. It was a,
in a defense of something that was
told to me when I was growing up.
So it's like I'm world champion,
so you can't tell that's not true
cause I'm world champion. Right.
So that's what that was about for me.
Making up for a lack of love,
lack of appreciation or just abuse.
Yeah. Lack of like, I'm not good enough.
So I'm gonna win this world title
and prove that I am good enough.
So FSU and that's not a pure
place to express yourself from,
you know, like now, um,
I'm more of a martial artist than I've
ever been and I'm more of a teacher and a
student than I've ever been in a more
of a champion than I've ever been.
How are you more of a champion
than you've ever been?
It's the way of my outlook and the way,
uh,
learn the way I attack new information,
the way how malleable I am.
Um,
how
quickly I take things
on, you know, how driven,
you know,
it's easy to be,
it's a lot easier to be champion when
you have the six pack and the muscles and
the youth. And the
everything, the back that up.
But when you have those things taken
away from you, then what is the champion?
What does it without those things,
it's your hearts, your desire,
it's your resolve. It's your mind. We're
using this expression champion. Like what,
what, why, why champion? Because
you're, if you're a champion,
you're competing against
someone to become a champion.
That was a big event chance,
right?
So to do it better, to
learn it faster. Yeah.
Over the things that you feel held you
back and limited your potential when you
actually were a world champion.
Kickboxer and so now it's
more about self expression.
You're more balanced
person. Yeah, definitely.
And now it's the pursuit of
self expression and as the
pursuit of authenticity,
um,
and like finding that moment to ride the
razor's edge instead of playing it safe
and staying outside but not having
a satisfying fight. You know,
even though you won don having satisfying
fights because you could feel the
flaws. Yeah. Well, I could just
feel how I was holding back.
And it's like you can feel when
you're in the zone and you go for it,
100% commitment and you, you're just in
it, you know, you're in, it would fights,
have you had where you
really felt satisfied? Uh,
I would say the fight after I
thought Julie. Yeah, she was,
I went up kitchen. Yeah. I went up
and wait to fight her. She, she um,
I went up to one 40. It was champion a
champion. She had 58 fights, I think.
14 world titles.
I had 14 fights at the time
and six world titles I think.
And um, that's pretty crazy. 14
five, six world titles. Yeah.
Yeah. Karen said that you were the most
talented person he's ever worked with.
I would agree.
I would.
I would because it's so high praise.
What I noticed is,
I mean, that's really,
it's amazing stuff. Well,
I'm malleable and I'm really dry lake. I'm
like, no, that's not right. Do it again.
This doesn't feel right. Do it
again. What am I, what are you doing?
What am I doing? What does it look
like? What should it feel like?
Where's my pressure? Where's the leverage?
Was this, you know, like, I'm like,
I'm like that, you know? No,
it's not right. Let's do it
again. Oh, that was perfect.
But let's move on to the next thing.
And this sort of level of dissatisfaction.
When you performances though,
don't you think that that's ultimately
what makes you such a champion in the
first place?
Like you,
Alexander Gustafson put it best once
when he was talking about one of his
training camps, he's like, this is
the life of a professional athlete.
You're just never satisfied.
He says, if you achieve,
if you want to achieve greatness,
you're never satisfied. No, I agree,
but not with the way I was doing it.
So you were doing it,
but you were doing it and I'm manic,
almost unhealthy way.
Like I could never just give myself that.
I never like, all right, that was great.
This needs adjustments. All
right, so here's the game
plan. You know, like, Oh, here,
you know, you did this, this is an
accomplishment. Uh, or you know, you,
you conquered this, you took
on this new scale. All right,
let's give yourself that credit. Right.
It's never good enough. Never good enough.
Never good enough. Never
good enough. You'll like,
is that thought like you'd
never good enough. Never
good enough. Definitely fuel.
It is right, but it's not, there's,
there's much more environmentally friendly
feel like this is like con pollutants
pollutant and as far as your life
goes, yeah, I know what you mean.
Yeah. Now, so, um, I am
working with, I am back at CSA,
working with Korean, you
know, but I told him, um,
for,
from Moitai I actually
told Dave and Kurian this.
I did well, I guess I'm telling him
no, if I were having a Thai fight,
obviously I'm not going
to, you know, I would,
I wouldn't be with anybody else.
Like he's,
that's where the success has been.
That's where the formula works.
I'm not going to change that. But, um,
now I'm also over at a gorilla
Jujitsu. Wait, Dave camera alone.
And so, oh my God. Genius
home. Fucking Jedi Knight Dude.
He's a Jedi Knight. Holy
Shit. Yeah. He's amazing.
He's amazing. Um, but now I get
to learn from him and so that,
um, does he make any where
g uh, he's not making me,
but I, I do and I would and have no
problem with it. Um, he's definitely,
he says like, I need to go to classes,
which I absolutely agree with, you know,
as a high level striker or any kind of
Stryker going into m a you need to go to
the fucking classes and learn
to swim in the deep end. Yeah.
You have to and just be
like, all right, this sucks.
I'm just getting like fucking armpit a
suffocated. It's fine. Just deal with it.
Um,
but uh,
with Dave I can feel myself changing
into the fighter that I want to be.
How often are you doing Jujitsu? Um, well,
right now I've been
traveling sometimes as much,
but I was doing it like every day.
Yeah.
And with your knee,
I know you have like a limited amount
of mobility with one of your name. Yeah.
Yeah.
Is that getting in the way of anything?
Um, it does definitely have to like
just put a brace on her or anything. No,
I just uh, communicate clearly
with my training partners.
So funny thing is I love heal hooks
and I've had four knee surgeries.
Isn't that weird?
It's a little weird. That's active as
fuck. That's the only submission I go for.
Really. He'll hook knee bar. Well
listen, that's a very good submission.
I mean it's revolutionized Jujitsu
I alley over the last few years.
The leg lock game is really taken over.
Do you think it was like if somebody had
that many surgeries you'd be like, no,
I'm not fucking with that.
Well how about John?
Actually I'm like getting in there.
John Donner as a fake hip.
He's got a fake knee. Oh Wow. Really?
His whole body's getting replaced and
he's one of the main minds at the head of
the leg lock revolution.
Eddie Commons being one of them and,
and then a lot of the students, you
know, awesome. Gary tone of course.
There's so many really good Jujitsu guys
now that are leg lock specialists fast
and Craig Jones is like a whole new crew
of up and coming guys that are leg lock
specialists. I love it. Yeah,
it's really interesting.
It's really interesting because
all the years that I did you Jitsu,
it took like this transition like which
only took place within the last decade,
like less than a decade where it really
started ramping up back in the day.
If you did it,
you just,
if you were in a Jujitsu tournament
and do the leg lock or a heel hook,
the crowd would boo. They'd
fucking scream. They would scream.
Even if you won by tap,
like if you went to the worlds
and you heal hook somebody,
people would freak the fuck
out. That's so dumb. It's crazy.
That's what it used to be. It used to
be that they thought of it as cheap.
They thought leg locks and
heal hooks and ankle locks.
They thought those were cheap moves, but
it's literally part of the body. Well,
it what it is is people that
didn't understand the defense,
so they would move the wrong way and get
their legs blown apart and nobody wants
to get their legs blown
apart and training.
So they would discourage it and training
and discourage it and competition
because it was ripping people's
legs apart. Retarded. Well,
it's just a lack of understanding what
your shoulder is a very complex joint.
We have zero problem manipulating
the shit out of people shoulders.
It's a weak joint to make joint
terrorism complex and unique. Yeah. Yeah.
And we have no problem with that.
Nobody.
Nobody says we gotta outlaw right
about that. Yeah. Somehow or another,
if you fuck your shoulder up, you
can't wipe your ass. That's okay.
But if you fuck your knee up,
we can't walk. Good carriage.
If you can wipe your own ass,
well not a problem for you.
Why over this with my super
toilet does toilets are awesome.
I'm going to take a picture of that
and post that on Instagram. Go ahead.
Feel free. I tell people about them.
They're amazing. That's awesome.
They keep it clean and pause.
It's comfy. It's like a warm seat.
As soon as I sat down I was like, ah. Oh,
nice. Right. Oh yeah. That's a good life.
That's good. This is the good life.
Yeah. Uh, it's weird. Like what? I mean,
why is it okay to yank on someone's neck?
I mean,
I didn't know so many dudes with
fucked up next. And he's like,
all of Jujitsu is bad for your body.
The tingling going down my arm right
now when I sit in certain positions, oh,
he's just wrestling and Jujitsu
never happened. No guarantee.
I know what that is. It's a pinched
nerve. Means you got a bulging disc. No,
that's what it means. Not
all the time though. Almost
always. No. The tingling. Yeah.
The tingling is called a nerve
is being pushed on by a disk.
Yeah. Most of the time. That's what
that is. Until the wheels fall off.
Yeah.
Well,
but the wheels are not off. You
can strengthen things and, and,
and you can do a lot of, have you ever
fucked around with spinal decompression?
So a lot of really cool devices that you
could do at home. Just hang spot. Yeah.
You put this harness on the straps to
the door and it like supports your head,
like pulls on your neck, stretches and
relaxes your neck. Yeah, it's fantastic.
Really good.
Yeah.
That'll help a lot and sign
that. And then after, uh,
we have pieces of paper you could write
on your paper. Okay. I'll text it to you.
I'll text you,
I'll text you all this stuff cause I'm,
I'm a fanatic about helping people
with neck injuries because a,
I had a pretty significant bulging
discs that was making my hands numb.
I was really worried and my elbow was
always in pain and I thought you're going
to damage my elbow. And it turned
out what was going on as the nerve.
My disc was pushing as a nerve in
my neck and then the ulnar nerve,
which goes all the way down to
your pinkie tips of my fingers.
It's like over here, right? Yeah. Yeah.
That was hurting weird since I
broke my elbow in her head. Well,
I'm sure it's all that inflammation
and scar tissue and shit,
but um,
there's a bunch of different devices to,
there's a thing called the iron neck
that I love to talk to people about too.
It's like a halo you put on those
help strengthen all this stuff too.
Yeah. I'll show it to you after.
After, after dupont pull on my,
I'm fine. I'm totally fine.
But wrestling like this
head cranks cranks,
even Jujitsu is not as
bad as wrestling for me.
John John Machado always says, never trust
your neck. Just don't trust your neck.
Never think you're next going to hold up.
Some guys like they'll shoot
him for a take down.
Someone will get them in a gay teen and
I just try to gut through it out of it.
Never Trust your neck, never
trust your neck. That sucks. Yeah,
neck is a weird thing. There's little
bones that are held in place by tendons.
And this gelatinous mush in between him
and in between is the fucking cord that
communicates from your brain all
the way down to all your limbs.
And we're cranking on that thing.
Like this is the housing for the cord
that keeps your body moving from your
brain and people are getting you
fucking chugs crushing your neck.
It's crazy now. Now when I do
Jujitsu and whole different mindset,
I'm really don't fucking touch my neck.
Yeah. Don't touch my neck. Don't make it.
I'll sneak an elbow in there.
Do you put your hair up and
buns and shit and like, yeah,
I try,
but it's
probably used to weld like lawn to,
you can pull it off.
Itchy moms wanting to choose mine.
I pull it off and should be done
it before you get a crew cut.
He'd look up bad ass bitch
with a crew cut. Like,
why not? Why not for a comeback
fight? Look in fucking,
it's not a bad move. I'm already
four. He's here, you know,
I got to at least keep some
kind of thing. Go take feminine.
Hmm. Okay. So I'm getting the lines,
I gotta at least try to rose
number units to the game.
I think rose looks just as beautiful,
if not more beautiful is she
know if she was an actress,
she looks like an a list actress,
doesn't she?
She has that presence but she doesn't
give a fuck. Like she's so yeah.
That's a big part of what it
is. So interesting. So present.
Beautiful. She is beautiful but beautiful
person. Her heart and hurts. Yes.
Yeah, yeah. No, she's amazing.
Yeah. Yeah. And um, they don't know.
I don't think they appreciate that as
much. They don't appreciate it enough.
You know,
like how gorgeous she is.
Like she doesn't get enough
press or attention or if she had,
if she had her hair and
she played the game. Yeah.
Cause she literally looks like a mini
supermodel with the little muscles.
Like, yeah. Well I remember when
she fought Michelle Waterson,
the karate hottie everybody's making
this big deal out of how hot Michelle
Waterson is,
who's very beautiful but so's rose
Rose's equally gorgeous if not more.
The look,
the,
it's a different type of
look like Michelle Waterson
would be like a hosting a
cable entertainment show,
ie news or something. Right.
And rose not Munis would be like
the lead in a, in a movie. Right.
That's the difference in beauty. She just
has this like, interesting look to her.
She has this kind of like a
challenging beauty, you know? Yeah.
And it's even her expression. Yeah.
We're, we're Michelle Waterson is,
there's something much more
comfortable about her beauty. Like
she's really exotic. She's like tie and
white or something. Right. Okay. Yeah.
She's gorgeous. But she, she's
doesn't have as something,
she hasn't had that challenging
thing. Do you know what I mean? Yeah.
I wouldn't look nowhere near as good as
rose, so. Well, that's very nice. Um,
so what kind of physical conditioning
do you do if you don't do any iron?
Next stuff? No, spinal
decompression. What do you do? Um,
I was doing a bit of crossfit and
a bit of, um, just fight training
as, so I've been out so long when I
started to get, be getting back in.
Like I told you before we started,
I went fucking crazy and that
was a bad idea at 41 at the time,
it was last year and I had a total body
breakdown where it hurts a full hold my
cell phone. I like burning pain in my
forearms, just holding my cell phone.
How long did it take you to
get to that spot? That spot?
About four months of hard.
Yeah. Like doing Jujitsu.
So I was over at half, Gracie
in San Francisco and I was
doing legs a hard spot.
Sometimes I do fuck around.
I know Kurt ender. Yeah.
Whenever I talked to somebody that
trained in house, I'll go, Ooh, yeah.
Fucking you swam with the sharks?
Yeah, I did. I did. Um, but it was,
how come you don't have Kurt on? He, he,
he called me. He's just like that in
person. Oh, I'm sure. It's just like that.
We're both friends with Bordain. I just
never got to meet for Dane was alive.
I'm sorry about that. Um, he
collects a medieval weapons
and he'll shoot them.
I love how we fucking takes videos where
you just see his feet and his feet,
those toes or isn't gnarled tape. They
seen his fingers. Yeah, there are a mess.
Yeah. Yeah. Well those gay guys, man,
they just damaged the shit out of their
fingers. I keep telling Kurt his big toe,
it looks like a, like one of those
dildos in the Castro. Like it looks like,
yeah, it looks like a, like a butt
plug. All those in the Castro.
Oh those,
it looks like a butt plug.
It's the like that big walls.
Old Guys,
their hands just turn into a gnarled
messes. It looks as though always trapped.
He looks like a mountain troll.
Little bit.
I love that guy is an animal. He
said, what else does he do? Yeah.
And he's a great cook is
too. And then also, um,
fuck. What does he do? Was he in
a band? He does a lot of acid.
He was in a band and he
like buys instruments.
It's like I'm gonna
learn how to play this.
And then he's like building
additions onto his house.
And did you start his own school
recently? Yes. That, okay.
That whole transition, that was
like game of Thrones. Oh really?
I don't know any quiz. I'm not,
I don't know that much about it.
I just remember like everybody
had little groups and was like, who are
you with? And it was just like, yeah,
I'm not really used to that. And
Moy, Tai, we don't, it's not as,
I mean there's some of it, but not like
that. And it's happening many times.
There's been many foldings and
unfolding. Are you with me, my brothers,
and I'm just like, ah, oh no.
I'm with myself. I'm just,
I'm just a blue belt. I want just a
12 year old blue blue belt over here.
You know? Like, I don't
really care how, I guess I,
I understand it because it really popular
school can be incredibly lucrative.
You know,
there's so many schools.
That's one of the weird things about
California that people like people that
live in places without a lot of Jujitsu,
they would go crazy here.
They wouldn't know where to go
within this. Where we are right now.
We could drive in three minutes
and go to five Jujitsu places.
I needed you to recommend some firmware
for me to train. I'm down here,
I'll get you a bunch of places. But
I mean we're in the valley, but I,
I could tell you there's a place in
it and see knows a place over here in
Woodland Hills has a place in Canoga Park.
There's a place over there.
It's a place over here. You can go further
out. I didn't even, they're everywhere.
Think about that.
Yeah.
Like being in an area
where there's no Jujitsu.
Oh there's places.
Yeah.
I mean one of the things when Bordain
was really getting into Jujitsu,
he was training every day even
on the road. So he travels, he,
well sometimes it's easy. It's hard when
you're a celebrity. Oh boy. Yeah. Yeah.
He would send me text messages about
it. Shit. Now bone fragments cause too,
it's just be smashing him cause you know,
they will sort of make an example out
of some celebrity guy who wants to learn
Jujitsu, crushing him. But
you know, he would go to,
like when he was in Bozeman, when he was
in Montana, there was no Jujitsu there,
so he had to go to like a club,
I think it was in billings
or something like that.
So He'd travel to where they did this
club and it was just a bunch of like
enthusiasts. They would get together.
It wasn't even like real teaching.
That's great. You know? And he
would train with them, play like a,
they have a TV with the video
up and they worked the move.
If you have a good good
video and a good athlete you,
you can learn something from that can do
attitude, a little bit of elbow grease,
a little bit of that man. I think there's
never been a better time to do that.
Then now with all the youtube videos,
it's really an incredible time.
Even if you're not in a place with a
really good Jujitsu, you can learn,
but you can definitely find something that
you really need someone to go, no, no.
I hear now go like this. And you look, oh,
just a little subtle adjustments that
someone knows from years and years and
years of training. It's all about
the sensitivity of leverage. Yeah.
It's just that sweet spot.
The Thai clinch.
It's just that like that little difference
if like when they putting the elbows
into like right in here and write
like pulling into that little,
that little hook area right behind
your head there. Yeah. I was working,
I'm helping some of the MMA guys at
gorilla with their Thai clinch and the one
of the wrestlers was grabbing up there
and grabbed the back of your head and it
kind of looks like they're gonna make out.
And
I try not to laugh, but
it's hard. It's, I'm sure.
I'm sure they want to laugh at me that
way. I did it. I did realize that,
oh, it's okay. Don't kiss him. Yeah.
Maybe later. This is not right now.
That is such an underutilized
a technique. You know, the,
a good plum, someone with a good
Moy Thai clinch. Yeah. I mean when,
if you haven't felt it before when
someone can really grow. Like,
I remember when Anderson
Silva fought rich Franklin.
Rich Franklin just did not
know what to do with it. Yes.
Anderson grabbed a hold of it and just
start smashing it and you realize like
the fucking clench the way he would do
to so locked down yet such technique.
Right.
You know what's funny to me as a Muy
Thai world champion or ex Muy Thai world
champion is that I watched
these things and I go through,
that's so fucking easy to neutralize. It
gets a little bit like you just, yeah,
just going to, you know, go like this
and what to do or you just like, it's,
you don't have to be in that situation.
It didn't know what to do. Yeah. Yeah.
But I mean to this day there's still
fights that I'll watch in the UFC where
I'll see their grappling and I'll just
go, Jesus fucking Christ. Get your foot.
What are you doing? Good.
Yeah. This is white belt stuff.
This is blue belt stuff surprises me
when I watch that. Cause I think like,
you know,
what do I know?
I'm in like a high level striker if I
don't like because you don't fucking know
this and you're in the UFC.
You don't fucking know this.
How do you not fucking know this?
It's you.
You're dealing with people that
come from all over the world. Right?
Like when Francis and gone, oh, fought
steep Emile chick for the title. Right.
Literally didn't is really recent, but
have you ever want to watch that again?
Yeah. It was rough to watch
ever. Yeah, I have terrible.
I don't really like watching heavyweight
fight that much. Why is that? Uh,
it's a little too slow. It's usually
not as technical. That's true.
But when they land, yeah, I know,
but I mean you can get people that are
smaller and more technical and faster and
they can land heavy punches too.
That's true.
But maybe cause you're there live so
you can feel the ground shake or me,
I'm just watching on the
TV so I don't feel it.
Did you see when Francis knocked
out Alistair Overeem? I think I did.
Yeah.
If you need to see it again and then you
need to see that again because this is
something that, this is some life.
Change my life. Watch this. Boom.
Yeah, watch this. I know
this boy, this left tour,
but it's crazy that I know.
So scary and his striking is so
dangerous that even Allister,
a guy who's been around forever,
he fought so wild and open.
His hands were down.
Yeah.
Where was his head movement and
where was his head movement? I mean,
he was moved a little bit in the beginning
of the consequences are so scary.
Yeah. Very little head movement.
Head movement. Have very little know.
Some guys are picking up more tattoo.
Yeah, no, especially Maurice. I know him.
Straight center line. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Well,
when I think guys like Simon Marcus start
working with Floyd Mayweather senior
and then other, when do you start
working with them? I don't know.
How long has he been with? I know. I don't
know. I just watch videos on the line.
Simon Marcus, number one on
the improvements. I'm sure
he's improving, but I dunno.
He's still pretty young. I mean, Simon is
only like 30 Simon Marcus, number one on,
um, Instagram. I think the real
problem with Moy Tai and, uh,
even with kickboxing is just a lack of
promotion and a lack of understanding
from the general public. To me, I get
very excited whenever a Gloria van is ana.
Here he is. Whenever a Gloria
van is on gimme a little zeroes.
It's been an amazing year as an honor
and pleasure to be able to work with
boxing legend Floyd Mayweather,
Sr four left at Jimmy said, kid,
you're going to be all right. It looks
good there, you know, but I mean,
you're talking about a guy with just a
tremendous amount of understanding of
boxing. Do you ever see when he
fought sugar ray Leonard Bending
his, uh, uh, uh, he's bending his
legs. Finally. Simon Marcus, right?
Oh, he's shifting his weight to, as
opposed to like the Moitai style. Yeah.
It's hard for him though. [inaudible]
Eco. It's, it's not like a,
it's not and easy. It's
like, yeah, but he's,
it's hard for him to rotate.
Yeah.
Isn't it interesting because yeah,
he's a world champion and
he's a devastating striker
and he just fucked a lot of
people up.
But the limitations of the style that he
imposes and the way, the way he does it,
when he's trying to learn a different,
more smooth way of doing things,
you see that the stiffness.
So in, uh, the boxing,
they generate that power from the feet
and the like, the rotating and the,
you know what I mean? Like kind of
like a gas pedal and a brake, right?
You're like, ah, ah, and white tie.
It's not like that. When they punched,
they're like, mm, mm mm.
When you say say it, like explain it,
explain it for people just listening.
Cause that's about half the crowd. Sorry.
Um hmm. They're like, what the fuck?
Um,
like for instance,
the rear foot would be the gas and
then the front foot would be the brake.
So you hit the gas and you're
going to go into the sprint.
But as soon as you start getting the
velocity for the sprint and you Bam,
put the breakdown. And then
with that, um, counter, um,
uh,
the contradiction or the opposing forces,
it erupts out the top in from your arms
and your fists into a powerful punch.
And I think with Moitai,
they just like step forward instead
of rotating from their tours,
from anything from their
feet and their torso.
Is there a benefit to that or does
it compliment the style of kicking?
A probably more complementing
the style of kicking,
but I think that if you move your,
if you allow for rotation your punches,
you allow
for the rotation in your feet so you can
generate more power and your punches.
You can still then take the necessary
step out at an angle and then,
um, and then stepping high with
your feet and get a great kick too.
Like you just, you can, you can have both.
You can have the best of both worlds.
Think combines the two things the
best. Oh, I love protrusion. Trojans.
One of the best armor.
He's amazing to watch. Protrusion
versus Andy Sour. Yeah.
Emma Asados face.
Yeah.
I think it's about time.
It's like get the fuck out this sport.
The fuck it was so good.
Well Petrosian stills at the top of
the game because they were women.
He hears these a Ben 10,
but he lost to Andy wristy.
Right. Was it Andy [inaudible] him.
How, what I have, that's another kid.
Now I, I will, I want to deal with
paper, but I need to see this.
Giorgio patrol geans um,
Instagram risk.
Is this where you got coyote or is
this a the sour fights? This our fight,
it was a sour fund. He was so young
here. Wow. I might not be in wristy.
See you can't Google it while you're
doing this. Kenya. I go, that's what,
we'll get to that afterwards.
But yeah, I like so sour.
Had this cut under his white.
Yeah.
And then it kind of goes like bleeding
a little bit. And then in his eye,
and this is assumptive on my part,
but in his eyes when you look at him
like interacting with the doctorate,
it looks like I, yeah, yeah. It's bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know what I mean?
Like why you'll,
it's further down in the fight,
but Giorgio is so technical and one of
the more interesting things to me with
Giorgio was watching him train because
a lot of it is drilling. I mean,
they do so much drilling.
Well,
that makes sense because you then
you can get out of the way. Well,
he knows exactly what to do is his brain
and his mind or in sync with what to do
in the middle of a furious battle so
that he doesn't have to think too much.
See that massage was excited. He's like,
yeah, I'm excited. This is exciting.
What's going to happen? Not towards
the end. That was fucking horses.
Yeah. Yeah. Once it starts
awesome. Kay. It's fucking amazing.
I just,
I just wished that kickboxing got more
press and more excitement in America
because I think it's more
exciting than boxing.
If there's more to look at you
and you're seeing with, um,
American champions, you, you're
seeing fantastic knockouts.
You see an amazing wins.
I mean,
the only one who's really doing all
the sports at a high level as Gastrin,
gastrin belong,
look at his face now.
This is after the first round.
Yeah. He's like, Oh shit, what time?
When does this go to the
distance? Um, yeah, I think, yeah,
go get into like the end rounds when
patrols you and really starts tuning them
up.
It's so interesting because he would
just sort of find out where your openings
were,
where the rhythm was,
where to move and we're not to
move and you're making mistakes
and like a computer when you do it,
you just see him plug in the techniques
to fill those holes and you'd see like
the little subtle steps and you know,
he always knows what you're going to
throw next or where you're going to be or
what you're going to do. And you know,
he's so amazing and there's the cut.
He was one of the best ever for sure.
And just an interesting guy to watch.
He does. He's doesn't look like he's
doing much like of that. That was,
he barely moved. Right.
Doesn't like doing much.
But uh, press housing is just
right there. He's barely moving.
Just moving. Just enough.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Somebody k owed him in glory. And like I
said, I think it's Andy wristy pull up.
Uh, I need to see that Giorgio
Petrosian record. I'm like,
what? Yeah. It was pretty shocking.
And it was in the big
Madison Square Garden debut.
They were in the theater at
Madison Square Garden. Yeah.
Just take lanky power of power.
Stryker think it was rusty.
Is it rusty?
It was.
He has fucking hard and he caught
Giorgio and boom, the lights went out.
Yeah. First round too. Yeah,
it was crazy. And again,
this was like glory had seriously hyped
up the fact that Georgia Petrolia is
like one of the best ever and
undefeated fantastic record.
And uh,
Andy Rusty,
maybe it was the beard. I don't think
it was, I think he just got clipped
and maybe it was also a lot
of pressure. Right. You know,
fighting in Madison Square Garden,
fighting on in Glory, glory,
putting all this stuff behind him.
And you know, the thing is too,
nobody ever knows what the fuck is going
on with a fighter when they're coming
into a fight. Right. You could be dealing
with injuries, sickness, training camp,
bad weight cut girlfriend.
I was talking to a friend of mine and
they were talking about how they were
dealing with their coach. Um, drug youth.
Their coach had a drug problem and they
weren't there for them for the fight.
And so they went into a world
title defense like that.
She said it wasn't the first round I was
wrong cause it looks like here we are
on the second or third. This is
the third, there's or the third.
So it was in the third round.
My memory's not that good. See
it's guy just made it a brawl.
Yes. Well he just made it ugly.
He's like no respect.
He also fucking hit super hard.
That's a part of the problem is it's
surprising because Patricia patrician
usually it doesn't get
entangled like this. You know,
he's really good at keeping,
oh, can we say that again? Or
they'll play it again. They,
he's really good at damn
uptown keeping space. Yeah.
He's really good at maintaining
a good range for himself.
But he's getting all the tangled up here.
Yeah.
I wonder what he thinks about this fight.
I would love to hear it.
I would love to hear like what was wrong.
Like what,
what leading up to this fight
speaks Italian cause translate.
Oh fuck. It's done that
before with Yoel Romero. I,
Joey Diaz translate for Yoel Romero.
That's why I'm like it or not.
This is the 44th 40 year olds,
uh,
not on steroids. Jammed full of
Jesus. Yeah. I like it or not.
I mean, and they're like, this is
amazing. He's a genetic freak. Yeah.
But you know, he was on the
podcast. He was talking about
it. He's like, go to Cuba.
He goes like, everybody looks like me.
He's like this fucking genes down there.
But it kind of makes sense.
You know,
I mean the slave trade led to all
these like reading and not just that,
but also high level athletic pursuits,
right? Because they're just there.
They put so much emphasis on athletes
and so much emphasis on, you know,
they probably have an athlete's
fuck. Other athletes, you know,
I mean if you get Serena Williams
and Lebron James to have a kid,
what are the odds that kid's
not a bad mother fucker.
It's 0% right. The kid
would be a beast, right?
It'd be a super athlete, seller
egg or the sperm cell, everything.
So it all put it together, combine it
and mix it up. I'd love to see that.
You imagine if like two super
athletes just decided like,
hey baby, I got an idea.
Like let's just find out. We can get
along. Yeah, let's just make a kid.
Or like not even, not even like a,
you know, hey baby. Just like, hey,
you want to just do a thing? It's
like eating. Then you'll just do it.
You care of me not fuck it
up. Yeah. That's the thing.
But they like a certain contract.
Yes. But here's the thing,
and this I wanted to talk to you about,
cause I know you had a rough childhood.
The reality is a certain amount of fucking
you up gives you a certain amount of
fuel that allows you to accomplish things
that a person with a cushy life and
always had a warm bed and always had
plenty of love. They, there's like a,
you have a good sure.
Right? For sure. Yeah.
You have a gear that someone who lived a
wonderful life with perfect environment
and perfect upbringing probably doesn't
have, it's more like like, okay,
I'll do it alone. Yeah. Like, oh,
okay. Right. But it's also the,
the need to do it alone.
The need to prove people, the
need to show people. Yeah.
You know? Yeah. Yeah. For sure.
Everybody I know that's interesting.
Had a fucked up childhood. Filey Yup.
I don't know anybody that didn't you
too. Yeah. Really. Sure, Huh? Yeah.
I haven't talked to my dad's. It's all
seven. He's alive. He's got the same name.
So cuddly and not bitter woman. Nice
person. And I have a lot of Nice friends.
Yeah. But I've, I've cultivated this,
this is something that I've
actively cultivated for decades.
We have worked really hard
to be a nice person. Yeah.
And I know the benefit
of being a nice person,
like how it makes me feel and
how it makes other people feel.
And I know that that spreads and it
makes other people nicer. And I try,
I work on it hard to
keep the wolf in a cage.
Always let out sometimes.
Sometimes. It's a lot of times.
I remember one time when you and I were
at a Moitai event together, um, uh,
you were there and I ran into you there.
And it's funny watching fights
with you because, uh, you,
you were, and you were, you were like
gritting your teeth and you were like,
and then you looked over me. He
goes, don't you don't even want it.
Don't you want to just fuck somebody up?
Don't you want to just smash some weights
fucking face? They're like, damn, Miriam,
I gotta get the fuck away from me.
When was this?
It was a long time ago in la.
Remember la had that pro
Moitai thing where, um,
uh, who fought a bull cow FOBT. Um,
there was some good,
it was a good one.
Oh my God. So you know what that
was? It was Moitai League. Yes.
So you know what it was, uh,
I had an ACL surgery. Right.
And I couldn't fight. That's right.
And I was supposed to fight. Right.
I was seizing, seizing, walking,
and I was watching these fights and
they were fucking garbage and I couldn't
fight. Yeah. Yeah. That was 2000. Oh,
I remember that. Yeah. God dammit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I was like, oh, it
would be these pitches. I really would
wish that event took off. Cause that
was fun. It was great having that in La.
Ernesto hoose was doing the
commentary as well. And um,
yeah, Ben didn't volunteer to fight
in that. I think she did. I would be,
had been very curious to
see how a Valentino versus
Julie Kitchen want to turn
out. Mm. Yeah. Well I'm interesting.
I'm really curious to see how she
does in the UFC at 125 pounds.
She's a beast because she's going to be
strong at that. Wait, that's her weight.
She's not a one 35 right. You see
how like she looks like fighter fit,
like lean and cut ripped.
Like even her legs when she was one
35 her legs look soft, you know?
And she was still winning. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. She dropped Holly Holm. Yeah.
That's crazy. I mean, she's Holly Holmes
like one 45 or probably, you know, like,
well she comfortably,
comfortably we at one 45 it's not like,
oh they're going a one 35 are going up
to one 45 she was like a big ass one 30
Fiverr and she went the
distance with Cyborg. Yeah.
At one 45 which is a fucking,
that's a statement in and of itself.
Well, it's just the boxer. Yeah.
So they're used to getting it
different. Yeah. Yeah. You know?
Yeah.
And I think she got fucked in the title
fight when she fought a Durand to me.
I thought she should have won
that fight for sure. I do.
And I think the cheap shot, the
cheap shot to sheep, cheap shots,
two of them after the bell,
one of them that significantly hurt her
and I think parents should have been
taken away for sure.
Yup. Yup, Yup, Yup. Yeah.
It's crazy sport. Holly Holmes,
amazing. She is as a person,
I've never met her,
but she seems nice person ever.
She seems really sweet and she just seems
like I was listening to her interviews,
you know,
it's just,
she seems just like a really uplifted,
genuine person, know a
super humble, you know,
she really is,
which is one of the weirder moments.
Why was such a weird moment
rather when Ronda Rousey at
the Wayans was like, you fucking
bitch yourself. You're a fucking fake.
And it was weird. It
was like, where's this?
It was like almost like she wanted her
to be the enemy so that she get amped up
to kick her ass. So sue sang a bunch
of things. It didn't even make sense.
Maybe even Rhonda was kind
of at a breaking point too,
just as far as like
workload, stress, level, um,
expectations, you know, obligations.
And when I saw that way in,
actually I,
I've watched that probably at least five
times. Like I just replayed it and like,
cause I like to watch people
interact and how they react.
I love it. Yeah. And I noticed
like when I saw that, I'm like, oh,
Holly's got this and I wish I'd fucking
bet buddy. It's totally, wish I did.
But now I was watching and I was like,
oh,
just stop because Ron Ron
to seem so emotional. Um,
it was the way Holly reacted.
That's why mm.
She's just,
she's just like Rhonda came in her space.
Holly just like stepped back, like
kept proper distance, you know,
like defensive distance.
I'm super,
super low key watch her reaction.
Yeah. She stayed calm for sure. Yeah.
That's, that's skinny Rhonda too.
That's way in Rhonda, which is like, she's
been depleted. Yeah. Yeah. She was Kinda,
she was to look how much
difference which is weighing in
yeah. Tied up and how he didn't give
any ground either and she's just like,
she stayed calm. She, she backed up,
but like she backed up like I'm
ready to hit you. Backed up.
She didn't back up like,
ah,
and then so Rhonda was a
super like emotional too.
She was funny. She was like,
all this is just trying to get a drink.
Yeah. I just thought I was having a drink.
I Dunno. Yeah. Yeah. It was
great. And then Ron was like us,
she was super right. And you never
saw her like that. You're like,
what the fuck? Yeah. Yeah. I
think you nailed it. As far
as the breaking point. Yeah.
She got sucked into all
the Hollywood bullshit.
They were putting her in movies and TV
shows and choose on different talk shows
as the type to like someone. Could she
beat Cain Velasquez? Could she, you know,
and it's like, oh my God, look
what she's doing to these women.
Could she remember that? Right?
There's like, wow. It was the creative,
she was a superstar. You know, I'm, look,
I was a part of this. I mean she has now,
she's still a superstar now.
She's a WWE superstar.
It's just a different kind of superstar.
Do you think she should? Yeah.
Well makes you say that.
Okay.
Like, don't go out like that.
This is Miriam target now.
It's a different person.
Oh,
she just,
she deserves better than to go out
the way you know her last fight. Well,
she deserves, she's exactly
what she got. She's,
no, no, this is what I think she's better
than that. That's think you're writing.
I think you're right.
That she's better than that.
It's bad that she got punched
like that. No, no, no, no,
no. I'm saying she, she just,
she deserves better than that to like
represent herself better than yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't think that matters to her as
much as it matters for other folks.
I think she really cemented her legacy
is one of the greatest women's MMA
champions ever in a pioneer.
But I also think that women's MMA has
evolved so fast that within the brief time
that she was running shit, the sport
passed her by. And when you see,
the one that I was always worried about
with her was Amanda. Cause I was like,
Amanda Nunez has a black belt in Brazilian
Jujitsu and nasty hands like to me.
Um, I think she has some judo. I Dunno
what her, her ranking isn't judo.
I don't know.
She could be,
but I know she's a black belt in
Jujitsu and I know she had heavy hands.
And my thought was at Rhonda, although
she was developing good striking skills.
She's known for a judo in her arm bars.
That's her big thing.
And the striking skills were sort of like
something that was happening along the
way and she was starting to catch girls,
but she was catching girls like batch
go, hey. Uh, and you know, and yeah,
and, and beating them down
when she gets them down,
they're not nearly on the
level of an Amanda Nunez.
Like you're not going to catch her
like that. And if she, right, exactly.
And my thought was that if,
if it was going to go down,
it was going to be Amanda because Amanda
just hit so fucking hard. And then,
so when she came back and immediately
fought for the world title against Amanda,
she needed a gimme fuck. Yeah, she
needed, she needed a different camp.
I think that's fair. She needed a lot.
She needed a revamping of her approach.
She needed a lot of things. She had
a lot of things because people knew,
first of all,
she never shoots for doubles.
She's not taking you down
with the lower body attack.
It's always upper body
and it's always a clinch.
And she clinches with her left arm. I
mean Greg Jackson, Jackson Winkeljohn,
they all figured that out. And Holly
had the solution for that. Yeah.
You know it also does.
Another thing is when you can't fucking
head kicked into oblivion that way.
Like you need a lot of time off.
A lot of time with the no sparring,
no nothing.
Especially as being so high.
I think so untouchable and high and then
getting coming crashing down to earth
like that. So it's rough.
That's a definitely like a big,
who am I moment? I think
I'm sure. Yeah. Well look,
can we talk right?
But you were talking about you trying
to figure out who you are when you
couldn't train anymore.
He and I had that on such
a s like small scale,
a pride compares private skill
and hurts personally but private.
And heres this the world.
Yes. In the whole world. Uh,
mine was like more tragic and hers
was more humiliating, humiliating. Mm.
You know, how was yours more tragic?
Um, it happened in third round
of a fight, a world title fight, MMA. Um,
it wasn't a clear like it
happened on a takedown.
It wasn't a takedown that Tor
twerked or tweaked my knee,
you're grabbed on my knee or it was,
um,
I pushed against them while
my body was like this, um, uh,
parallel to the ground and
uh, I tore my own ACL. Yeah.
So it was like, why is that more tragic?
Um, because it was more like, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Um,
I think it's more humiliating to
get knocked out, in my opinion,
to get knocked out sure. Than it
is to get like, injured out, like,
like tear, tear out, like still fighting.
And then you'd step back and you,
everything slips and you fall. Right.
Because your knee can't, it's gone. Yeah.
You know, that's what I mean when I say
tragic or if you're like winning the,
winning the for the fight. And
then unfortunate. Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
So it's more
fortunate and then your identity stripped
away. But again, yours is private.
Hers is public,
but at least you understand what it's
like to not be that person who you di you
counted on,
you being that person as part of your
shield that you put on to go through the
day.
Yeah,
for sure. For sure. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So her persona, um, she's
damn good at it too.
And then it's like stripped away.
Well, she was the first, well,
Gina Carano was the first, right.
The people sort of identified with like,
wow,
here's this pretty girl who
kicks ass and this is crazy.
We never seen this before, but it was
at a smaller scale. People just didn't,
they didn't kind of understand who she
was or what she was [inaudible] it wasn't
as big. Yeah. It wasn't nearly as
big as tiny in comparison. Yeah.
But then when Ron came along,
it was like this perfect storm.
It's like the UFC was huge. Everything
was taking off and then here's his girl,
just fucking everybody up
hers. Hers was much
more, uh, violence to me.
Then Gina's like, she'd like, you're
getting slammed, right. And just like,
you know what I mean? And
when your arm broke. Yeah,
basically like recruit some super group
when she fought Misha and cranked her on
the show is amazing. 21 tab man. I
snapped her arm and half. God Damn. Yeah.
And she's still not tapping. It's like
a tearing the chicken and the, exactly.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
I mean she has a bad ass for that
one now during all this time.
I mean this is when
Rhonda is taking off and when Holly's
taking off and Amanda Nunez is taking off
all this time is when you're at your peak,
you're at your peak as a fighter and then
you're dealing with all these fucking
injuries and you're working your
way to get into this circus.
I mean, you're, you're working in way to
step into this arena. I mean, this is,
this is like ultimately
this was your goal. Yeah.
What the fuck is that like to
be just sitting there on their,
dealing with all this bullshit
watching else do it. Yeah.
Oh,
it was maddening.
Well I think about the time that I was
sitting next to you watching those fights.
Yeah.
Do you want fucking smash him
making me fucking nervous.
It was worse actually.
So that time I only blew up to one 65.
Um, this time I blew up to one 86. Yeah,
it was big. Well, you use, that's
almost, that's almost one nine. Yeah,
it was 200. Yeah, exactly.
Exactly. And uh, I was um,
I'm drinking and it was an eating ride
and I was, yeah, it a bunch of stuff.
So how'd you turn around?
Um,
ultimately I think,
so I taught rock steady boxing.
It's a Roxy to boxing is a program for
people with Parkinson's disease and it
teaches them how to box
and that helps them, uh,
with their symptoms and their quality.
It improves their quality of life and
gives them a sense that it gives them a
community to, to be in. And the
interesting about rock city boxing was,
I thought I was going to be,
it was a terrible fit and I was terrified
that I was gonna hurt them and it
actually was the best fit.
And they loved being in my classes and
I love teaching them and like honestly,
they healed my heart.
Like they healed that.
Not good enough that I felt wow.
Yeah.
It was pretty crazy. So teaching
and helping people. Yeah.
We're brought it around for you and
like seeing understanding that I can
definitely understand like,
my body is doing this and I
want to do that and there's,
I can't do anything about it,
you know,
and that frustration and it's infuriating
and I'm like watching them go through
what they, they go through
and it was just incredible.
And they just show up and they,
they,
they just work so hard
and they're just fighting,
scrape a little grandmas
and grandpas. Wow. Yeah.
Did you see the rock city
video? No. Uber. Uber.
Uber did a mini documentary on me.
Yeah. I've never seen it. Yeah.
How long has it made any documentary?
Can we watch two minutes now.
We'll get kicked off the internet if
we pull it off and put it on Youtube.
People always claim it or we got our
videos taken down unfortunately. Oh,
watch it afterwards and I'll tweet
it. Yeah, yeah, I'll put it up.
That's fucking awesome.
And I'll make you,
it might make you tear up a little
bit or to Europe. Easy. Let me too,
I'm a crier. Like, it's not just
like sad or like I'm happy I'll cry.
I'll actually, after you asked me to be
on this podcast, I was having moments,
there's like kind of crying all
ever since because it was just like,
yeah, I was just like, Holy Shit.
So for me, coming back to fighting,
I,
it's Curian was like,
we were talking about a game plan about
coming back and um, he's like, okay,
so this is what I think. I think,
you know, getting the right fight,
like getting a moist, high
fight, maybe WBC diamond belt.
And that is like all I wanted when
I was active fighting five years,
that's all I fucking wanted.
Like it broke my heart,
hurt my heart that they wouldn't
sanction that for women.
It was so frustrating to me. And he's
talking about that and he's like, yeah,
we'll get this fight and then that'll
be your way to come back. And I'm like,
I don't give a fuck. I don't want
another world title. I have enough.
Like how much fucking good
enough do I need to be? I'm done.
Like I just want to be paid. Like just
fuck you pay me. I saw all I want.
They go. And so when I you say that,
but once you start preparing, no,
I'm still going to do,
it was fucking best of my ability.
But I'm not like I would take a fight
that's $1,500 $3,000 for a world title
fight to get a chance to fight for that
world title. Like now I'm like, hell no,
no. I will take a non world title
fight that pays more over a world title
opportunity.
Or are you looking to compete now in MMA?
Are you looking to compete and Moy
Tai or are you looking to compete in
kickboxing? I'm looking to compete in
whatever pays me touching. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. So dollar mode. When you asked me
to be on this podcast and I was like,
Holy Shit.
So this in turn would get my followers up,
which in turn would make it so I could
get paid more the next time I fight.
Do you see that? Yeah. And
I was just like, oh my God,
this is so like thank you so much.
And it was just like, you know,
I was just feeling like my eyes welling
up with tears and I felt hella nervous.
I was like, oh my God. There's like how
many subscribers on this shit? Oh Geez.
Can I say attention to what I was like,
she might be doing a good job. Not
microdosing today. No. But,
um, what I said to myself,
cause I do, I did feel very nervous and
I do still, but when I said to myself,
I was like, well, it wouldn't be
happening if he weren't ready.
So this didn't happen before
when you were active fighting,
you're winning all these world titles.
Like you weren't ready.
So you're ready now. That's
a good attitude. Yeah.
But I would have had John back
then too. I wasn't ready. You,
I'm sure you would have been fine. No,
no, I wasn't ready. Really. Yeah. Yeah,
for sure. Cause I think I didn't know
myself the way I know myself now.
I didn't trust myself.
I didn't have everything taken.
All my strength taken away from me
and then I'll come out of it by my,
yeah, I mean like one of the things that
the rock steady boxing got me back in,
like help heal my heart.
But also the other thing was like,
I kept trying to train, I kept trying to
get better. I kept trying to, you know,
and lose weight,
but my knee was still fucking with me and
I'd get inflammation and this and that.
And so finally I just said, you know
what? I think Dominick Cruz did this too,
where he's just like, maybe I don't
get to fight again. Like maybe that,
that's just what it is and
I'm not crying. You're
crying. It's okay. I just,
okay,
I've cried on this project.
I made peace with that and then
things started getting better.
I don't know.
I don't know why or how,
but like somehow like fixating,
it wouldn't let me move forward.
Like it just kept holding onto it like
wasn't when it wasn't working or I'm
going to said, okay, then I don't
get to fight again. All right,
let it go. And that's when
it came back to me. I Dunno.
Do you think that,
I think will,
I think that for the average person that's
watching this and doesn't understand
this fixation on fighting,
I think it comes back to what were talking
about before that it's so difficult
and so rewarding and so
impossible and you're,
you're finding out about
yourself during the struggle.
And then it is my therapy.
Yeah. It doesn't like,
so I used to do a lot of drugs.
Like I used to do math where I
weighed 126 pounds. I'm five,
nine, that's not normal for
me. And I did so much partying,
so much drugs,
so much like self abuse.
And then I started training and I used
to smoke a pack of Marlboro reds a day.
You know, I would go on benders and
stab like four or five days in a row,
you know? And, uh, I started training Moy,
Tai, and that's when I stopped.
Like, it wasn't immediate,
it wasn't like quit cold Turkey,
you know,
I just like over time as I moved towards
the goal of fighting and it took me I
think five years before I fought.
So I started training [inaudible].
It took me five fucking years. And, um,
I stopped doing drugs, I stopped
partying, I stopped smoking, I stopped,
you know, I started having a
more disciplined and disciplined,
regimented lifestyle and it was just
refining some people get sober through
working the steps.
Training was my steps.
Training was my way of
getting to know myself and getting to
sift through what wasn't me and what was
me.
I was told a lot of things that I was
when I was a kid and I come to find out I
wasn't those things. I'm hardworking, I'm
disciplined, I'm intelligent, and I'm a,
you know, I'm all these other things
that I was never told I was, you know,
and it was all through fighting.
So yeah. Well, fighting
gave you a venue that gave you
then training. Yes, but
I think fighting made me,
I know because if only I'd trained,
I wouldn't have
gone as deep as I needed to
go to get to the shit. Right.
That fucking like,
you know,
the cart crust layer that
you got to fucking dig under
and like get in there and
sort of go through that stuff.
Yeah.
You would have polished yourself up
a little bit. Yeah. But it wasn't,
it wouldn't have,
he'll do changed my makeup or
even allowed me to be who I am,
you know?
Yeah.
Like right now it's kind of a trip.
Like I feel like I'm in bloom or just
learning faster than I ever have.
It's easy. And uh, like Dave,
it was tripping out on me because he was
watching me train or watching stuff I
was doing.
And it's so much easier to do the
things without bullshit in the way.
Bullshit and your brain. Yeah. Yeah.
Bullshit in my brain and my emotions,
my like these limiting beliefs
about myself, it's so much easier.
Or, or to finally be able to
be in a space where I'm like,
okay, you're doing this.
What am I doing? Okay.
I'm not matching what you're
doing or what are you feeling?
What am I feeling where I think a lot
of people, when they first start out,
they just do what they're told
instead of questioning the concept,
questioning the, you
know, so it's, it's just,
I think the more mature I get, the
easier, the more I know myself.
So the easier it is to get the information
that I need to master the thing.
Well, this is always
the, the, the big race.
They're big races to achieve
maturity before your body does. Yeah.
Before your body wear and tear
on the spotty, on average,
especially anybody in combat
sports and sports at 42 yeah.
And to be able to achieve
enough mental maturity while
your body is still pliable and,
and, and viable, it still works
and you can still execute.
You still a vitality isn't Demetrius
Johnson? Amazing. Fucking amazing.
So amazing.
Yeah.
I'm not even thinking about all the
incredible things he does without a fight.
I'm thinking about his
post fight interview.
Oh, he's fantastic. He's amazing.
Yeah. No, he's just an awesome dude.
He's so just like right there,
isn't he? Yeah. He's like, no,
this is what I do and this is what it's
going to happen and we planned for this
and no, no, no, no, no, no. And
that's it. Super. Matter of fact,
well his coach Matt Hume is
one of the grades. Absolutely.
I want to meet that guy. I just love to
watch that training happen. She's like,
get to get to be able to pick up on the
energy and the magic in the room. Well,
I'd like the fact that he's now going to
one FC and one FC is going to pay him a
fuck load of money in the US on your
season is weird state where the reality
financially about the flyweight division
is, it's just not a big, big cell.
It's not like people are dying
to watch 125 pound dudes fight.
People don't like tiny men.
I mean,
it's weird because it's the first
one is going to take that as a quote.
Take 10 of the context. Probably going
to be a picture of you standing there.
Jack, the six pack with
belts on. Pete talked about
tiny men like they're out there other
man bits or something fucking weird.
That's also a thing that people don't
like. But the thing is like, see,
I'd like I said it, I don't like
watching heavyweights fight. Right.
I like watching the smaller weights fight
cause usually they're more technical.
Well he's just technicals there's,
and he's, he moves seamlessly.
If this would is talking about being
about being able to be authentic,
express yourself from moment to moment,
you know,
and not have to like play it safe and
stay back and stay outside in a way.
And yeah,
he's just in there and he flows.
He also does what we talked about earlier
where I said that I don't think you
should ever fight stupid.
That you should fight within the best
so you could express your abilities and
your techniques the best.
And that's what he does.
Situational condom on every,
you know what I mean?
Even though he's being offensive, he
still has protection. Right. Listen,
situational condoms, condom. It's a funny
way of putting it. Yeah, that is true.
Yeah. Is, um, what are you
leaning towards you? I mean,
I know you're saying like,
what if you get an equal offer,
an equal offer and Muay Thai
and equal offer an MMA would,
what would you lean towards?
I would want to do MMA,
but tie it would be, yeah man. Wait
has never fucking loved me back.
Whoa. Serious Shit right
there. I said, man, I'm still,
I was never loved you back.
No. So that's some deep
childhood shit right there, Mary.
Yeah,
Mary world or world champion childhood.
Like I had my baby beginnings
as a champion. So do you also,
first of all,
you have a massive advantage and
stand up over most girls in MMA.
That's also been a deal. It doesn't
matter if I don't make the adjustment.
Of course, of course. So
I can't think that like,
oh, I'm better because like
oftentimes with a lot of MMA,
MMA fighters and Cesar Gracie
said this to me, he's like in MMA,
the girls, they're like pit bulls.
Like they don't have the technique,
but they have, they have the,
they get by on the toughness.
So like with a pit bull you like you'd
have to kill it, right? Yeah, yeah,
yeah. There's a lot of that
for sure. We'll definitely, um,
fluster the fuck out of
a high level striker.
I mean look at the Petrosian and rusty.
Yeah.
Yeah. But in diversity is pretty high
level too though. But I've never seen,
not that I've watched all
the puck Trojans fights,
but I have never seen him get entangled
like that, that often. True. That is not,
and risky. Just made it ugly. He
made it a brawl. And that's why you,
it's an interesting fight. But who knows?
Like I said, who knows where he was at?
What was going on in his head? Injuries,
sickness. Who knows what happened?
That beard. The beard. Yeah. I Dunno.
Cowboy Cerrone looks as good as it's
ever looked his last fight. Yeah,
but that's phony. That's not
petroleum for traditions like sexy.
He's got the sexist, the Toronto, me,
Donald, Donald Cerrone's not sexy.
Not like the way Petrossian
is like everything.
Petrossian is like pretty the things he
does, the way he fights. It's pretty, oh,
I see what you're saying. It's
like part what? He's sexy.
He's like patrol and he's Italian.
Okay. Yeah. Yo come on Georgia. Yeah,
I see what I mean. You shouldn't have
that fucking beard. Plucked them up.
Made them less aerodynamic.
Okay.
I'm a big believer in beer power.
So my dad had a beard growing up and
now I see all these 30 year olds,
20 year olds hipsters with like their
beard oil and their periods and I'm just
like gross.
I have a real problem with beards with
men that looked like they would break
real easy.
You know I can't stand man with
skinny necks. Yeah, that's a,
that's an uncomfortable buff
dudes with skinny necks.
That means they're not doing
anything because I'm just like,
that's shit's not real. Right. You'll
get, you'll get fucked up. Yeah.
That's just not real. You can't fight.
Your head's barely hanging on there
like a chicken and the third world country
where they just like that and rip the
head off the chicken.
Well it shows a severe lack of core
strength cause like if you're doing like
dead lifts and if you're doing
anything with your traps,
you're going to develop a thick neck.
If you're doing anything where you got up,
hoist things up off the ground,
you have a look at those mother fuckers
in the Olympics at do dead lifts.
They have giant ass net. Then I gradually
anybody they have huge next. Yeah,
because they're doing this whole time
that's all fucking neck and back and the
whole spinal column has to be strong.
He looks scary, man. It's guys who are
doing this shit and then they're posing.
They pose it
guys with Nintex has the modern,
yeah, he's got no neck. He
taps quick. That postures.
That is a preposterous snack.
I feel like if you had kicked him,
he might die. Right. It's not, his
head's not going to be attached.
He snap that shit down.
Look at that.
Yeah.
Jesus crazy.
He's like a pit bull in that was the dark
days right before that was the court.
But when they were putting them
in jail for rape, did he do it?
What does that article say? If you have
a no, I don't, I don't believe he did.
I might be wrong, but that girl, um, she
falsely accused someone of rape earlier.
Oh yeah. If you have a thin neck,
you're my most likely a Beta male.
How about takeout? Most
likely. How about just you are,
you are a Beta male. Who's, who's out
there running shit with a thin neck.
You can't be running.
Shit been there.
How could you be running shit with
your mom's house? Got this guy.
You probably hold that net guy.
Damn long neck.
What do you mean it's got the
longest? Who's this guy? Oh,
I thought I have seen that guy.
Yeah,
I thought you going to bring up that
guy who's been in the Internet. Memes.
The dude who's now fighting MMA.
Black Guy who's neck starts at the top
of his head and goes straight down here.
He's got the craziest neck
Evers. You said a weird neck. Oh,
I thought it was just like distorted.
Oh No.
There's a bunch of pictures of this cat
and was like, oh, they just did the thing.
They didn't do.
The thing do does a nutty neck.
You know some girls have giant tits.
This guy is just to neck. Yeah.
I mean some people, huge hands.
He's going to start fighting MMA.
But where's he from? I Dunno. Probably
Florida. I buddies from Florida.
Look at it. Look at his neck. He got
arrested again. What does it say?
When did he get arrested?
The first one you look at as ne,
well someone's going to teach them,
but what is going on with that neck?
That's his real neck. That is fucking
crazy. That's like he's got a double neck.
Maybe just a small job. Now that is a big
neck. What are his parents look like? Um,
I bet they have giant next to I
put the chips off. Genetic mom.
Mom's a thick old dog
looking lady first please.
Smoke shot showed off his really big neck
this time he's not smiling so it's the
thing. Same. So he's probably power
lifter or something like that.
Yeah.
And plus got a fucked up neck.
No need to blow poor man's spot up.
Just fucked up neck.
But I take his neck over the
skinny neck. No, you know I,
maybe his neck is like
genetically fucked up like that.
And maybe the go with a skinny neck just
doesn't work out like the situation.
It's not, it doesn't bug me when
somebody is just, they have, you know,
slender neck.
But when they go through so much
trouble to look like an Alpha male,
but they have that little chicken neck,
right. And then they're posing like there,
that's gotta be a big issue with you.
Like as a woman,
like the way you interact
with men as a world champion,
Muay Thai woman even figured that out.
You have to have a hard time with the men.
I bet you do. I do. Yeah. Yeah. Cause you
need to get a real one, like a real, real,
like that's the only way it's
going to work. That it hasn't.
Now imagine it's hard out
there for a pimp. It is.
Right.
So I had is a great boyfriend,
but we went out of country.
We fought on the same card.
He fought the day before me.
I thought the next day during the
fight he almost gets knocked out
as this guy is mauling him.
He goes like this.
What do you think?
I was thinking.
Okay.
Um, not good dogs. The
boyfriend, the boyfriend,
my boyfriend was like this.
Yeah. You didn't like it?
Fuck now to turn you off. Oh my
God, so much. Whoa. I was like,
dude, you're getting fucked up and you
drop you as you're falling to the canvas.
You need, still need to go. Fuck you.
So the way he was getting
beaten was fucking with you.
It wasn't just that he was getting beaten.
I don't care if he wasn't
like,
take that shit. Yeah. Like you know,
like a champ or like, or like a fighter,
right? Yeah. You can't be like, wow, whoa.
Yeah. That was great.
Maybe sometimes it's like that's
the problem. It's at the balance.
The ones who are not great boyfriends
are the one that are going to turn you on
because they're ruthless.
Yeah. Yeah. It was like, I can,
I can balance that shit. I got
to be ruthless, gentle. Mm.
I was like, I don't not. Well, I mean,
I'm sure someone can sweet kale chips.
It's great. Yeah. I get it. I
don't get it. Some people can.
Yeah. Yeah. But I mean, I
think your requirements,
particularly as a fighter,
but going to be extraordinarily high as a
world champion fighter. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was was better off dating a guy who's
like a navy seal or something who can't
fight or maybe and fight, but he's
not a fighter. He doesn't like it.
Knows how to fight, but he's not,
he's a killer. He's not in there.
Maybe like you could relate
more. Yeah. I don't know.
I think your dating has it.
I'll try it out and I'll let
you know. Well I've, I've,
I've, I've noticed this, I mean
except for the ones that are lesbians,
I was looking at women who are fighters
and I hope they're limited in their
dating pool.
Cause girls who are fighters,
they don't want to date
someone who can't fight.
The last thing a girl wants who's like a
professional fighter or if somebody was
really smart,
you know what,
even if the guy is really smart
because it, because then they like,
as long as they asked me somewhere they
have to really fuck. You're like, no, no.
You could say that. You're trying
to find a nice man. He was like,
maybe I can compromise. No,
you need a killer. No, it will.
It would've bothered me about
that was like, you're a fighter,
but you're not being a fighter.
And I'm just like not savage enough.
Well,
you worried that if the shit hits the fan,
that's what every woman is worried.
If the shit hits the fan, what?
How do you react?
And you don't really know until you see
someone react when the shit hits the fan.
And when you see the shit hitting the fan,
you see them going, yikes. You're like,
fuck,
I can't count on you to,
I think he would have been better outside
of the fighting situation outside if
the shit hit the fan.
Oh.
So it was definitely like
writer's ego, like, Nah,
dude, you need to have more
bright than that. Well,
how you do anything is how you
do everything. Okay. All right.
Maybe. Yeah, especially duress.
I mean, people make mistakes. People
panic. People learn from those mistakes.
I mean,
there are people that fold in fights that
come back way stronger and will never
fold because they folded before and
they felt it because you made a mistake.
You know, you, you,
you make a split second decision in
the middle of a fight and you know,
and something, something
inside you, you, you, you,
it exposes weakness that maybe you
weren't prepared for the world to see.
And then when you feel
the pain of that weakness,
you make a vow that you're never
going to experience that again.
That's entirely possible.
I feel like mental strength is not,
I don't think you either have it or you
don't have it. I don't buy that shit.
I think you can develop it.
I think you can build it.
And I think mental toughness and just the
ability to persevere is something that
you can cultivate a really believed
that. Absolutely. Absolutely.
So maybe he needed to caleel shying away
and feel you going, hey motherfucker,
you know, when you get in the head,
don't, don't do any of this shit.
Maybe someone needs to hear that. So then
when it's happening they go, fuck that.
I'm not doing this anymore,
and then they dig deep and step to
the side or clench or do something.
Go out like a warrior. Yeah. You
know, or figure your way a better,
better response to the situation.
Then again,
sometimes you get clipped in.
Your neuromuscular system just
goes up and everything's just off.
It's just you're not responding right
because your, your system's getting shot,
but it was more like, get away from me.
That's not good. Yeah. I didn't like that,
Miriam.
We said two and a half hours flew by.
It's four 30 that wasn't scary at all.
It wasn't scary. I told you my friend,
I'm going to take care of you. We're all
good, man. Listen, what have you on again,
when you have a fight scheduled
and we'll pump that shit up. Okay,
let me know when. Let me know
what it is. Bare knuckle boxing,
whatever maybe. Right.
They're doing a lot of that.
You've got to go to Wyoming and do it on
a ranch or something. Right? Hey, well,
does it pay well? Yeah,
it does it way more real.
I know somebody that did four rounds
for 10,004 rounds for 10,000 yes.
You say that like that's not,
that's a lot of money for that. For,
for just boxing. Four rounds
about boxing. Bare knuckle.
What did he break your hands?
We'll talk.
Tell people how to find you on Instagram,
on Twitter, all that stuff. Oh, I'm Mary,
I'm Nakamoto.
Spell it out so people know.
High R I a M Nakamoto.
Okay.
Hold on. Nakamoto Nakamoto. It's
on my Instagram. She's linked.
She'll be linked there. All
right. Thanks man. Appreciate it.
Bye Buddy.
Hi.
Hmm.